Person to do it on their thing,
like we're plugging into it.
We're live.
We're just discussing a very critical,
um,
sound engineering issues.
We will take care of on the next version
of this studio.
I'm going to build something either in
downtown or near here and we haven't
decided.
Really.
I always figured you'd had it here
because you live here.
Yeah,
I do,
but I like downtown.
I like the idea of being on the top of a
big building.
My other option and I had been looking
at land.
My other option is in Topanga Canyon to
build an actual compound.
My problem is I'm afraid because I know
me.
I don't necessarily trust me.
I'm afraid I'll go whole hog Colonel
Kurtz and start a real compound once I
have the actual land and start putting
things in and realize I'm not really
that restricted financially from
building shit.
I might just start getting crazy and
then you can put all your followers
could work.
That's the problem.
Then that becomes a problem.
The unstable ones shows up with the
fucking suicide vest.
Downtown's a bit of a pain in the ass
though.
Getting theirs sucks and I did.
Someone had a show down there and I had
to park like in this weird thing and cut
through a macy's to get to the where the
thing was.
Downtown can be a little tricky unless
you get a cool,
so ho kind of loft space.
That's what I'm thinking.
What I was thinking of is getting a high
rise,
like a top floor on a high rise.
Get crazy and get something with the
most dope,
ridiculous view and have that view be
the background when we do shows those
especially nighttime shows,
that'd be pretty sweet.
And a good vantage point when the
earthquake comes.
Have you ever been in a high rise during
the quake?
Well,
I'm going to have a parachute for you
and for Jamie and for all of us and
we're just going to shoot through one of
the windows.
I'll have a shotgun blast through one of
the windows and they were just going to
jump.
I was in San Francisco two summers ago,
not last summer.
The one before during that earthquake
they had a little up in Napa was napa
one.
And uh,
I had a show there that night.
I'm in a high rise,
get up to go to the bathroom at around
two in the morning on my way back.
But the whole building,
like a rubber band just back,
I was like,
what the.
Oh,
they were on rollers and that thing just
scariest.
I just laid on the bed and it was like,
all right,
maybe this is going down.
Maybe it's laid on the bed,
laid on the bed.
I just,
yeah,
just kinda collapsed on the bed.
Like you're supposed to get into a
doorframe there was,
there was nothing but just tech.
Yeah,
that's completely really weird.
And I was like,
and it was,
oh,
I'm like to,
I just go to the airport,
actually just get the hell out of town.
Right.
Start running towards the middle of the
country.
Brassica that was my instinct.
I looked out the window.
I didn't see people like running and
drove.
So I just said,
well this,
we'll see how freaked out I am if I can
just
go back to sleep.
And I did just fell asleep.
Did you ever read the article?
Was It in New Yorker?
I don't remember what magazine it was
in.
There was an article that was
essentially saying the Pacific
northwest,
like Seattle is a ticking time bomb.
It's just a matter of time before it
gets hit by a massive tsunami and an
earthquake.
One hundred percent going to happen
might happen in 100 years.
Might happen into who knows?
Yeah,
I'm going,
I'm going there this weekend.
You Parlor,
live,
love that place.
Good Club.
That combines my two favorite things in
life,
pool playing pool and the comedy club.
It's almost like they designed it for
me.
It is pretty perfect.
I haven't been there in awhile.
So what?
What happens?
Like when they say like at that level
that they say it'll hit what happens to
like,
does that mean like Seattle goes into
the ocean?
The Article?
It was the New Yorker,
the really big ones by the way,
received so much hate and I think
fucking threats and all kinds of crazy
shit that she had to.
I think she had to make an amendment to
this,
but not so big one to say,
hey fuckers relaxed.
I didn't mean to scare you.
I'm just a notice like Mexico seems
fine.
Look,
it goes all the way down to California
all the way to the see the appeal that
they're showing in the illustration.
Think Mexico's our move.
Come on Tom.
Papa.
Let's do it.
Let's go.
San Diego might not be a bad spot
either.
It doesn't seem to be.
It's like falling off.
It's not two quickie.
No,
and it's filled with military people.
They'll know what to do.
Yeah.
Pendleton.
Yeah,
they're right there.
Tell me what to do.
That's a good spot to be.
If the shit hits the fan bunch of
motherfuckers who prepared for the shit
hitting the fan.
Do you have a kit?
A Kit?
Yeah.
Do you have an emergency kit?
I have food and food.
Dried freeze.
Dried food and water.
Keep it in the garage.
Fridge.
Yeah.
Well,
I have a garage freezers,
freezers in the garage,
and have giant coolers that'll keep.
I have these yeti coolers you ever said,
you know what?
A yeti cooler and Yeti coolers are
really high end.
A hunting coolers,
outdoorsmen cooler.
They will keep ice.
I use it when I Brian,
things like if I Brian,
a ham,
like I smoked Hams.
You ever smoking hand?
No.
Oh,
so delicious.
Yeah,
man.
There's nothing like it.
It takes a long time to do it looks like
six days to Brian it.
Six days.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
but then once you smoke it and then cook
it,
like right out of the smoker and then
serve it.
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
My kids scream when they eat it because
it just melt in your mouth.
It's just so tender and moist and
delicious.
So where's the cooler?
Come in?
What do you mean you.
I leave it in the cooler for six days by
itself in a bucket.
So I,
Brian the ham.
I take the ham,
I put a bucket of water with salt,
garlic,
some brown sugar,
and a few other spices.
I forget what it is.
Some Himalayan pink salt and then it
sits in this cooler.
I surround the cooler with ice or
surround the bucket with ice.
And I lock it down and I just leave it
outside for days.
She's six days later I opened up and
it's still got ice in it and really see
that.
That's one that I cook.
Oh man,
that looks good.
Yeah.
Five hours.
Two hundred 50 degrees.
How many pounds is that?
That was about,
I wanna say like a three pound one
somewhere.
She was so good.
Oh my God.
Like you cut like you see all the juices
at the bottom of that plate?
Yeah.
It's like you cut into and it's just
squirting in your face.
It's so good.
So good.
Jesus know that is wild.
Wild Ham.
So that's my warning.
The apocalypse is what you're going to
live on.
Well my point is that those yeti coolers
can keep things cold for a really long
time.
So like you could have like if you have
frozen meat,
it'll stay frozen in those things for a
week.
Right.
Or at least cold enough where you don't
have to worry about it going bad.
So you can keep all your stuff in there.
So I have meat that'll last for a week
of like a week of meat and then okay,
generator.
I have a generator,
I'm going solar though I'm turning my
whole house or I think I am as well.
It's crazy to not in California.
I know it's you have to drop pretty good
cash at the beginning.
Yes.
It'll take about five years to get it
back.
You might not ever get it back.
I might not ever.
You can have it set up where you're
always going to have power and you're
completely off the grid.
Right.
That's the big thing.
Which Brian Cowen has been trying to get
them to turn over to his soul and he
says they're really resistant.
Yeah.
He paid for panels.
He had the whole thing set up and he's
like,
it's really interesting.
He's like,
they make it super difficult for you to
do this because they,
they're fighting the uh,
the solar companies,
they don't want them to be autonomous.
They don't want people to be autonomous.
They also want you to be connected to
the grid if you choose to remove
yourself from the grid and be just a 100
percent solar.
It's a huge issue.
Yep.
Very hard to get done.
So Ken,
has he cut off completely but he's not
not.
So you'll pay like a couple cents a
month just to stay on.
I don't know.
You'd have to talk to Brian,
but for for the longest time,
I don't know if he's gotten it turned
over,
but for the longest time they weren't
turning it over.
Like I'm talking about six months.
So he makes a sizable investment.
Spent tens of thousands of dollars and
there's all this equipment installed in
his yard and they wouldn't turn it on.
He's like,
I couldn't get them to turn it on.
I have a tesla and I want to go solar.
So it's the car so completely.
But the battery,
the charger,
you can get a rebate off of this thing.
The amount of paperwork you have to show
the city of La for them to give you $700
back is you have to take pictures of
your house,
pictures of the charger,
receipts from the company.
Uh,
certificates of work,
things from the panel.
I mean,
it's a list of like 12 things.
It's like,
you know,
and uh,
I,
if I have to go to the,
to the mailbox once with the right
stamp,
like it's going to take weeks for me to
pull that off.
Your comment,
I'm not,
I'm not doing it.
I'm like,
all right.
I guess going to play ball.
Yeah.
They make you do $700 worth of work.
Your $700,
where exactly you would think they would
be the opposite.
You'd think they'd be.
No,
you think that they would encourage it
because it would ease the grid.
I rented a Tesl for a day because we
have a sponsor,
it's called Skirt as k,
U R T,
and they're real new,
but what they're doing is they're
essentially like uber for rental cars.
So like say if you were outside the
comedy store and you're like,
hey,
I need a rental car,
I want to drive to San Francisco,
they'll fucking show up in 20 minutes
with a rental car and you'd take that
bitch and drive it up to coast.
She's,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you have an application or on your
phone,
right?
You use the APP,
you order up a car and you can get a
tesla.
So I said,
okay,
I want to try this service out before we
do it.
Let's get me a tesla.
So I got a tesla.
It was fucking services excellence.
Show up.
They give you the thing,
they give you the key that you do.
You know how to do it.
I said,
yeah,
I watched a couple videos.
I'm good to go.
Okay.
It's real strange because the tesla
doesn't start now and that's a,
that's a weird one for people.
You get in it,
you go,
okay.
Why isn't it starting?
There is no revenue gas.
There's no gas,
no brum,
brum,
brum at all.
No.
And it just sort of,
you put it in drive and okay we're going
o k,
but what got me was how quick the
battery drained.
I was like,
Ooh,
oh,
like this.
How quick did it train?
Well I live out here.
You were just about half hour to the
Improv.
I drove all the way the Improv back.
I drove here home,
back to the Improv and back home and
then back here and it was more than a
half a tank.
More than half.
More than half gone.
I'm like,
that's not 240 miles.
Like that's.
But that's half.
That's 1:20
in the.
But it's not even,
it's not even,
it's maybe 60 miles where the driving
maybe.
Were you punching it?
You must have been because it's a fast.
I don't think I drive any other way to
do it.
There is a big difference when you're
slamming it was like a thing and yeah,
it shows you like the sweet spot and
that's around probably around 65.
It's ground grantee level.
But man,
when you clash that thing,
yeah,
it's crazy.
But it eats up the juice.
But it's weird how it accelerates
without gears,
which is very hard for people who have
driven a regular car to comprehend,
but it just,
it's instant on.
So like a golf cart,
like a Mongo golf cart,
the golf cart.
It's fun.
Even going from zero to 30 5:40.
Yeah.
Just to get that punch.
It's a wonderful car.
It's amazing.
What they've done is amazing.
I came here from down around Wilsher,
like Beverly Hills area.
Get on the four or five,
hit autopilot and I didn't steer until I
got off of shut the fuck one-on-one.
Shut the fuck up.
I didn't touch the brake.
I
didn't touch the accelerator.
I didn't steer.
We taxing.
I looked at a text.
I looked at a text that freaks me out,
man.
It drives better than I do.
What is it doing?
Is it?
It's got a camera and it's scanning the
environment.
Cameras and sensors.
So it's on the.
On the dashboard,
it'll show the two lines that are picked
up visually.
It'll pick up the speed based on a sign.
And then it has cars,
shadow cars around you.
It's reading all the cars around you,
Jesus,
and it just,
it just goes.
You said it at the,
at the speed,
like control and it just breaks and if
you want to change lanes,
just hit the directional and if it
thinks it's safe,
it'll change lanes for you.
Well,
my,
uh,
I have,
one of those Lexus Suv.
Yeah.
And it'll accelerate and decelerate
depending upon the traffic.
So it has a laser sensor and it gives
you options.
Like you could ride someone's ass and
it'll do it that way or you could spread
it out whereas like four cars in front
of you,
it starts to break,
which is the way I have it set up
because I don't think it doesn't break
that good.
It's a giant ass truck right in traffic.
It's pretty great.
Like when I take my kids to school,
I'll hop on the one on one and I'll,
uh,
to not have to deal with the braking,
stopping going.
That part is just sweet.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
It's really great.
I mean they say a car insurance
companies are getting ready for the
collapse of their business.
Good.
They say once everything is automated,
they think this is the insurance
companies talking,
that it's gonna be an 85 percent
decrease in accidents.
That's how much better the car and I
know the car is a better driver than I
am.
No more conscious,
sees more was long as you have the
option to be autonomous on a country
road,
you know,
as long as you get on a country road and
you could just fucking zoom around and
drive and see things.
You mean do it on your own?
Yeah.
Because when you get on those roads,
like I put it on autopilot,
go into the comedy store and I go from
Sherman oaks,
Sherman Hooks over Laurel,
Laurel Canyon's,
wavy gravy and weird turns and people.
And it's,
it's a little nerve wracking.
So when you're doing that,
so you're doing all those turns.
It's doing it completely by itself on
Laurel to appoint.
Oh No,
I don't like that to a point.
That's what I'm saying.
That's the scary.
That's the scary part.
So was,
it doesn't really cause you know Laurel,
it's old road that you can't read the
lines.
There's a lot of weirdness going on.
You can't.
I've tried it,
especially when you come back down
towards Ventura and there's like that
really whipping turns that you don't
want to just let the car do it.
Maybe it's going to be one of those
things where they're going to be forced
to have to Redo the roads to deal with
these electric cars that have to read
the centers.
Maybe the other thing is I think the
technology is going to be gps driven
also,
so
that'll help if it syncs up that way the
government can just fucking shut you
down and pull you over.
They get exterminate you if you do
anything wrong.
Well,
you know,
that's the.
That's the grand conspiracy theory about
Michael Hastings.
Do you know Michael Hastings is.
Michael Hastings is a journalist.
He wrote an article for rolling stone
about a general who was involved in the
war and he was embedded and while he was
embedded over there,
just coincidentally it was when they had
that big Icelandic volcano.
Remember that?
Icelandic volcano?
Yeah.
Well,
it globally crippled flights for a long
time.
I remember that all through Europe.
Yeah,
so he was stuck over there for I wanna
say like an extra month and when he was
stuck over there,
they got a little too coffee with this
guy and they started cracking a bunch of
jokes about vice president Biden,
who's that?
The soldiers and the general,
and I don't remember,
mcallister was at Mcalester,
which whichever general believe it's
mcallister.
He had to step down after the article
came out because the article was just
absolutely brutal and it was devastating
and so this,
this Michael Hastings character started
receiving some serious tangible death
threats that like,
you're a dead motherfucker,
like we're going to find you like you
just,
you just cost American lives because you
just got rid of one of the best generals
ever because you don't think it's
politically correct that this guy jokes
around about a guy like Joe Biden who is
obviously a fucking goof,
right?
Joe Biden's a group,
he's a goof and if you don't think he's
a goof wise in the running for
president,
you know,
why isn't he running?
Ladies and gentlemen,
who were a bunch of reasons.
One of them,
Joe Biden was a plagiarist,
like Joe Biden when I was in Boston at
stitches comedy club in 1988 weeks back
when he was running for president,
but he had abandoned his,
his campaign because they found his
speeches were just gigantic chunks of
President Kennedy speech and snap.
Yes.
Still from Kennedy,
Kennedy.
Nobody knew back before the Internet.
Nobody knew that you couldn't get away
with shit like that crazy.
But he got away with it because of
actual political scholars who are like,
Hey,
fuck head.
I know that fucking speech.
So we at stitches had Joe Biden tonight.
We would do Joe Biden tonight.
What do you mean?
Well,
we would steal each other's shit.
Ah,
like if you went up,
you would do my act and I would try to
remember your at.
We would try to remember each other.
It was great.
That's got to be fun.
Yeah,
it was,
um,
Kevin Fitzgerald,
who the hell did I forget who?
Forget the comic who started it,
but either way it's a great idea.
That's how much of a plagiarist he was.
Never heard that.
Yeah,
he was so well they keep the Democratic
Party,
keeps it under wraps now,
but it was a big story in 88.
So what happened with this?
So he started getting death threats
because he was talking shit about him,
started getting some serious death
threats because this guy was a love
general,
very respected by these people who
worked for him,
including soldiers,
including Spec ops guys and all these
people who looked at this Michael
Hastings.
I like you piece of fucking
shit anyway,
and he's just a guy just to replace the
report just to report,
but a snarky little fuck,
you know,
let's do an adderall and a bunch of
other shit.
He was a little cocky.
Anyway,
this guy drove a 120 miles an hour
without hitting the brakes into a tree
on sunset and died under very suspicious
circumstances.
Not only that,
he was telling people that if he dies
like you should understand that they
killed me.
Really not going to kill myself if I
die,
just know this.
They killed me.
And when military experts who understand
what's possible today comes to
automating vehicles.
Yeah.
They say it's absolutely possible.
Absolutely.
People are hacking into commander cars.
These cars like your crying that can
drive itself.
Yeah.
Like this is a Mercedes and the Mercedes
have that same ability.
Yeah.
Especially the new ones do.
I don't know if his did,
but what they're essentially saying is
would they could just pin that fucking
accelerator down,
just lift off that gas,
lift off that break so the break doesn't
work at all,
and then disable,
disable the bags and steer that
motherfucker right into a tree.
Oh,
that's how they kill them.
That's how people think,
right?
Of course,
his family and a lot of other people who
are close to them,
they don't want to say anything.
They're probably terrified and they say,
no,
we believe it was suicide,
you know?
And,
but,
but the people who knew knew him outside
of his family,
like,
that is nonsense,
isn't it?
So it's,
it's a credible conspiracy because
you're talking about a guy who,
through his article,
like the rolling stone article was
devastating to the military.
It's really devastating to.
Wasn't mcallister to the point where
general has to step down.
Stanley McChrystal hastings and crystal
crystal profiled the CIA director.
John Brennan.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Okay.
And yeah,
he was working on a pro,
another fucking expos day of the CIA
director Jesus fucking Christ.
So it was really interesting.
What was really interesting and um,
you know,
I just have to be worried about someone
being in the audience of the comedy
store and like he's a hack and they take
out their cell phone and make me go into
a tree on Laurel,
like the CIA is not going to care.
But in angry audience member.
Well that's.
He fucked with.
What was the general's name?
Stanley McChrystal.
Mcchrystal McChrystal and the CIA.
Yes.
Yeah,
I mean it was a double whammy of fuck
ups and it's almost like they wanted to
see what they get away with.
Like,
let's see,
we haven't used this shit.
Let's try to use this shit stateside.
Oh man,
this motherfucker nutri because got to
be able to be.
Because when someone riding a snarky
article like that,
I mean I don't know what actually was
said or I didn't read the article,
but apparently it was very disturbing to
the people that were involved there and
what he had decided to do with this
article from their point of view was
take a very inflammatory position.
The he tried to,
you know,
manipulate it and make it very negative
and you know,
they,
they can do things like that if they
writing an article about it,
if they read your article about you.
Well,
it's amazing.
I mean when you think about just
technology and I'm so excited about this
car,
I'm so excited.
What it can do.
It's amazing what we're.
All this stuff is going.
You just talking about that service.
We'll just bring it a rental car to.
I mean it's all and it's moving so
quickly and so great.
But I tend to only think of all these
positive,
cool,
fun things that you can do with it.
You know,
the evil guy,
the evildoers it can use that same
stuff.
And then some.
I mean,
in their mind,
they might not even be the evildoers he
might be a real problem.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
he might be in their eyes and enemy of
America,
I don't know who's right,
but if he really did interrupt some
military operations at cost soldiers
their lives because the general wasn't
there anymore because he had to step
down and it fucked up the entire chain
of leadership.
Tevye and he was talking about in that
same article that Jamie put up that he
was around,
he was,
whenever he was around people who kill
people for a living,
they would invariably tell him we're
going to kill you.
Like it wasn't.
It wasn't,
uh,
a couple people that were saying this to
him.
Like there was several people there
saying,
hey motherfucker,
you're dead.
Just so you know,
we're all,
we're all going to kill you.
So this guy,
what did he do?
He doubled down when,
after the CIA,
afterwards,
God balls the balls on the.
This young man,
he tested positive when he died for
crystal meth.
He did,
yeah,
it had,
um,
verify that just to be sure that he had
had a,
an issue with drugs in the past.
Apparently from all this stuff that I've
read and uh,
they thought he'd kicked it,
but you know,
death threats will fucking get you right
back on the wagon or off.
It doesn't work on the line and I'll
have them off the wagon or do they plant
that on him?
Well,
it's easy for him.
It's his body.
It may or may not have been real.
Who knows?
And it also that stuff a crystal meth
and adderall are so closely related.
They're,
they're almost the same thing really.
Yeah.
Adderall is very,
very similar to Crystal Bailey.
Yeah.
She's,
well,
it's just a,
a nice healthy dose,
right?
We don't have to worry about dying.
Right.
Or running down sunset with no pants on
or you know,
you'll,
you'll get productive instead of
destructive.
Productive and destructive are next door
neighbors when you're on adderall.
Apparently.
God,
that was the scary thing when they were
talking during the Republican debate
about how,
how much heroin is in New Hampshire,
how it just nobody,
not one person brought up prescription
drugs cause the lead into that.
Well,
they can not.
One,
they can't.
There's just too much money.
Yeah,
it's the pharmaceutical companies have
been bought and sold.
It's a criminal.
It's a criminal business.
The whole business is entirely criminal
as far as politics,
the business of politics,
the way they get money and what they can
and can't say otherwise.
They would be talking about cigarettes.
Cigarettes kill a half a million people
in America alone every year still.
Yeah,
still.
Yeah.
Does.
It's not changing like dropped off a
little bit,
you know,
with education.
But yeah,
people are fucking dumb man.
They,
they want those things in their mouth.
It's amazing,
isn't it true you ever tried smoking
once as a kid we were walking down the
street and we saw a lit cigarette.
Someone who must just put it out of the
car.
I was just walking with my two buddies.
I picked up a cigarette and imagine if
that's how you got herpes,
be such a memorandum cigarette.
I coughed so much.
It was like that is all and it was like
probably 11 and that was it.
I was just like,
no,
I'm not going to smoke.
It was good for you.
It was just a lucky break,
you know?
I smoked with my sister when I was 15
and she was 14.
I tried it and she tried it.
She kept smoking until she was in her
forties.
I think it really,
I think thirties,
late thirties maybe.
I never smoked again.
I just know this is ridiculous.
It just seemed.
I like the idea of it.
I like holding something I like a lot of
times when I'm out with friends,
let's have like a roll up of Napkin or
something and just.
I just like the authority of it.
It looks cool as fuck.
It looks good.
It's the coolest.
Oh,
just come out of a show and just light
up by yourself in the,
in the hallway.
You know what's funny?
When cigarette smokers looked down on
cigar smokers like,
fuck off.
I love cigars.
Cigars are great,
but it's funny when someone lights up a
cigar around someone to smoke
cigarettes,
they'll be like disgusting.
Like,
oh my God.
You know what,
those fucking cigarettes.
You smoke.
Smell A.
Yeah.
The worst.
The best is pipes.
Pipe,
smell.
Great.
Know pipes really?
I know.
Pipe smell good because that doesn't
offend my family,
which is all girl.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
They're like,
oh,
that's not so bad.
Oh,
forget it.
I can be in the backyard.
Shut all the windows blown.
I might sound with a cigar and someone's
going to pop their head out of a window.
You're disgusting.
Yeah.
I love a nice cigars.
A cigar over here from Michael Dowd.
These are from there.
Probably dried out.
Now I got to get a human to remind me
again about a human.
Got a humidor at home.
I got to bring it here.
Yeah,
I got this from.
Did you ever see the documentary?
The seven five now.
Nick Depaulo told me about it.
Oh yeah.
Holy Shit.
The seven,
five,
seven.
Five is about the seven,
five precinct in New York City and it
was in the seventies,
the eighties rather during the crack
epidemic.
Oh yeah.
Holy Shit.
Oh really?
What a fucking crazy documentary.
And Michael Dowd was one of the corrupt
cops that was in it,
in went to jail for
a long time,
the whole deal,
but then got out and then they did this
documentary and he did my podcast.
Oh really?
Yeah,
and he brought in some cigar.
So he's having made if that's his
business now.
Well he's doing a bunch of different
things.
You just kind of hustling.
It's hard.
It's just got A.
I mean he was in jail for a long time
and tried to put his life back in order.
She's just got caught up in all the
money and oh well it was 20 something
years old.
He was young and all the cops are
corrupt.
He like the first day on the job they
were explaining to him about a guy who
quote on quote jumped off of a roof and
it was because this guy had ratted on
cops.
He was like,
that's what happens when you ran on cops
that.
Got It.
We're good.
One of the elite the first week or
something that he was working,
but he was like.
It was really real clear.
Real early on there's a giant percentage
of guys are on the take and that's just
how you made money.
So where does he get the tobacco?
I don't know.
I don't think they're made in the
Dominican Republic.
He's got a friend that he used to do
quote unquote business with back during
the cocaine days that he's pals with
visits.
I think that's where he's getting.
Yeah,
I got a bunch of Cuban cigars.
Cohibas.
Ooh,
Nice.
It really is a difference.
Yeah.
The other visitors to get the real,
the real deal.
You got to make sure you get real ones.
Yeah.
There's a lot of fucking counterfeit
cube.
There's a lot of fake.
He's going to open up now though soon,
but they don't have enough quantity like
the.
I forget the name of the area where they
grow.
There's this area specific era via whole
trabaho or something like that.
I forget what it's called,
but it's a very small area where they
grow the best cigars and the soil is
like incredibly rich and they've been
tilling the soil and taking care of it
in a very specific way for decades and
decades and they just know what they're
doing and now America's coming in and
wants to devour it.
Yeah,
right.
I mean,
because they do sell them around the
rest of the world.
I used to get them from England.
Oh yeah.
I used to get them sent to me from
England.
Allegedly.
It's not legal.
No.
They would send them to me and then like
a couple weeks later they would send me
the bands so they would send them with
like Dominican bands and then you'd take
them off and then they'd send you the,
the actual real,
you know?
Yeah.
My friend a Gad Al-Mulla that French
comedian.
No,
it's like the biggest comedian in
France.
And uh,
I told him that I had gotten a little
while ago that I had a Cuban cigar.
He's like,
no,
you don't.
I was like,
yeah,
I got them in touch with.
Did you get them?
I said,
my buddy got.
I'm from Vegas and he knows a guy who
knows a guy like Tom.
I'm telling you,
Americans do not get the Cuban cigars.
I will bring you some that we have in
France and then he brought some stuff
from France and I couldn't really tell
if it was different,
but he.
His point was Cuban will deal with us.
What you're getting is just rehashed
horseshit.
You definitely can get.
I mean,
yeah,
you can.
I think the ones I have now or are we
are legit maybe.
I think so.
The only way to really know is to get
them from Cuba.
Yeah.
And even then you don't know,
right?
They can be shipping them from Dominican
Republic to Cuba,
boxing of being Cuba with their own
wrappers and sending them right to you
to save money.
Yeah.
You're right.
I mean once people realize that there's
so much money in America now.
Yeah,
I still don't think you can just go hog
wild on by like 50 boxes of them.
I think there's a limitation on how much
you're allowed to import.
I went to Canada,
I went to a,
uh,
to a warehouse guy that dealt with Cuba
and then he would sell them to the
stores in Canada,
so it was all through the government and
pr and legit and stuff and that was
pretty trippy just walking through a
warehouse of all heaven.
Humidity control.
Yeah.
Perfect.
It's interesting how they have to do
that.
Right?
They have to like keep the cigars at a
certain level of humidity,
but once they do that,
they last forever.
Yeah.
And you can bring them back to like,
if you get,
if this is dry and you have,
you just literally come back apparently
a couple times.
Is that it?
Yeah.
After a while they just turned to shit.
You got to be careful of mold to.
They can get mold.
Where do you smoke your cigarettes?
Where the fuck I want in your house?
I'm a man top.
I do whatever the fuck I want.
Your no outside go outside.
I could do it in my office but open up
the window.
Yeah.
And to have some fucking sophisticated
methods of ventilation.
Yeah.
Let God do they hate it or if you just
come home and it's still on your
clothes.
I had signs of like,
come on in here.
That is going to show you what to do.
I know I'm going to show you what that
dope.
It's not.
It really repels every female for miles.
Well,
girls who don't get repelled by it.
I do not trust that fucking scandalous
bitches.
Smoke.
Um,
yes.
Yeah.
Those girls are fucking dangerous.
Girls will shoot.
You got a gun in her pussy.
Don't trust the.
Oh,
one of those.
she's one of the guys coming over for
the superbowl.
Right?
She loves sports too.
Come on.
I don't even have a female friend.
Will when you meet a girl,
doesn't have any female friends.
Yikes.
That's like a guy who doesn't have any
guy friends.
Yeah.
Ladies,
if you ever have a friend who's a guy
and he doesn't have any guy friends,
that guy's gay.
That's the only answer.
Explanation.
It's right to an explanation or he's a
fucking psycho.
You're psycho.
Yeah.
What kind of a man doesn't know your
friends?
I like hanging out with women.
It's just like being with the girls.
Women are real.
The more real plus they talk about shit.
I'm interested in shoes and like what
they're really saying is I can fool
them.
Guys know I'm full of Shit.
Yes,
definitely that.
Yeah.
Male feminists were an asshole.
Fucking the Mazda.
You say that.
Say that again.
Say it again.
I'm on your side.
Yeah,
I'm different
ladies.
He knows a lot of men are just.
They're just rude.
The guy in college with the Acoustic
Guitar.
Fucking animal house scene.
Yeah,
exactly.
That was one of the great scenes in
unmasking gets fucking fake.
Pseudo sensitive autistic behavior,
which by the way ladies is just for
Pussy.
If we were all camping together,
that guy would not break out the guitar.
It wouldn't happen.
It happens because girls are around and
he wants to appear to be being
insensitive and it's the same as a male
yoga teacher maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe some guy with his little diaper
out of that guy.
Well,
even better than that.
He had a fucking warehouse filled with
like Ferrari's and shit and they busted
him and he said that this was for a.
He was going to start an education
program for children on automotive
engineering was the beak room.
Automotive Engineering Center.
I'm not bullshitting.
He just got caught with this.
That's hilarious.
They just,
uh,
he had to,
he had to pay or he just got a judgment
against him for millions of dollars for
sexual harassment and fucking with
people.
Yeah.
He was banging all of them.
Well,
it's not just banging because if you're
banging all of them,
you see they can't get money from you if
you're banging them,
you have to be rude.
But he was,
he got to be rude about it,
you know,
if they like you and you're having sex,
like I want some money.
Well,
what did you like having sex with them?
Yeah,
but I feel like I should be getting paid
yoga mogul from mogul being from should
ne should shouldery must pay almost six
point $5 million in damages.
There's a photo of him and the yoga
place that I go to,
he's sitting there like in the Lotus
position on a tiger body,
like a skin tiger with the head.
Like a rug.
You can find it.
Yeah.
There's a tiger rug.
It's so retail.
It was always in that diaper.
But what did what kind of mixed signal
you send him,
motherfucker.
You murdering animals.
You don't even eat tigers,
you know?
This isn't like.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not like,
you know you ate an elk and you have the
horns there.
No,
you don't eat fucking tigers.
Like what are you doing,
man?
Why do you have a skin tiger?
Tiger.
There's the photo.
It's not just one of them because
that's.
That's a different one than the one
that's in my yoga studio.
That hair,
the hair's more offensive than the time
while he was going bald.
So what he did it just grow it long on
the outside.
Did the Ben Franklin.
I'll admit I've thought of it.
Here's the thing about those classes,
men,
there's something about yoga classes
that are almost inherently sexual.
Yes,
there it is.
Central.
It's hot,
everyone's in their underwear.
It's definitely that one.
Yeah,
that shot.
It could all those girls look at him and
it's a little and then he brings him in
and he's like,
you can be a teacher and he wins.
It's a cult.
That's the danger of it.
It's.
He really gets devout
followers and then has sex with amount
of tiger.
Seems like no matter what,
if there's one person that's some sort
of charismatic leader like that,
and then you're doing something
spiritual like yoga,
someone's gonna run a cult.
Yeah,
I've absolutely not all powerful.
Yeah.
Not all of them like to go to a good
place.
I go to this place in a Gaura and the
lady who runs it is fantastic.
The group has found a great place,
but it's a warm place and I was asking
her,
I was like,
okay,
Rachel,
like,
uh,
this guy,
speaker guys,
a little fucking shady.
Like,
what's the deal?
Yeah,
they say that he's a very good teacher,
but he's an asshole.
That's how everybody looks at it.
I totally get it.
I mean,
it's,
you're surrounded by all these beautiful
women in these sweaty scenarios in a
certain key to fuck him.
Exactly.
They're tired of her husband.
He's boring.
This guy,
spiritual.
I go this great.
Normally I go to a place in Sherman oaks
called black dog yoga.
Oh,
okay.
And heard that place.
It's really good and I've fallen in love
with a couple teachers.
They're no joke and of course you have.
There's a couple classes that are lambs.
There's a couple of minuses.
They know there's a couple of classes
that are like right after you drop your
kids off at school,
like a 9:00
start where it's not like the 6:00,
7:00
at night,
young hard body going,
yes,
their moms.
I got a couple of kids or even older.
It's not like you're saying,
okay,
I'm going to do a photo shoot in here
for whatever magazine.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
you know,
regular,
regular looking people.
You go to that class for a couple months
and you start seeing the same people
over and over again.
Everybody starts looking really
attractive.
So it is essential practice.
It is a,
there's a thing to it.
It's hot.
It's hot and wet and everyone's naked.
Yeah.
I keep my shirt on.
Do you?
How dare you?
I'm scared.
I'm not scared.
I feel like as a guy it's 90 percent
women.
You should kind of just try and be
invisible in a yoga class.
Get the outside row,
keep your clothes on.
This is really their thing.
And you're kind of visiting is their
thing.
Yeah,
but the guy invented it.
I invented now he just,
he just took yoga and made it sweaty.
Well he just.
No,
he just added.
He just put a bunch of poses in a
sequence and he tried to copyright that
sequence but he was turned down so
there's people that he was suing.
He's a very sue,
happy person.
So like if someone's say allegedly I
should say allegedly is a sue happy
person.
Right.
So if somebody.
I don't want to get it.
If you were one of his disciples and
started your own school,
you had his own program and then you
said,
you know what,
this guy is kind of a Douche.
I don't want to pay him money anymore.
I'm just going to go off and just call
it Tom Papa's yoga.
You will get sued.
Really?
Yeah,
but even though he didn't invent any of
those poses,
so he gets a piece of every bikram
around the world.
That's where he's making all that.
That's why he's got all that Luke and he
was trying to say that the,
the sequences in order,
the way that he's putting them together
have some sort of a right,
an extra powerful property to them and
that that was his patent,
but I believe we check on that because I
believe that was turned down.
Yeah,
I believe it was.
He still made all that dough.
Yes.
He made a lot of fucking money.
You're probably still makes a lot of
fucking money,
but at the six point five is not going
to make them flinch.
I'm sure he's got that and cars just
laying around.
I know.
I mean,
you know,
you go once in awhile.
It's 10 bucks a class.
How do you make them that much bank?
Well,
if you have thousands of schools all
over the country and each over the
world,
really in each one of them pays you,
you know,
whatever.
500 bucks a month.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
that's,
that's where it comes from.
So here goes.
The court affirmed that although beak
Rome had copyright protection in his
published book on the sequence,
he could not thereby invoke copyright to
stop others from using the sequences
described in his book.
Uh,
yeah.
See that's like,
that's like someone teaching Jujitsu and
saying you can't teach those moves,
right?
Julius,
who's been around for so long,
you could never,
you could never do that.
Yeah.
This guy was born in the sixties,
you know what I mean?
Exactly what we're here to take over
yogas.
Thousands of years old,
the balls,
the balls on this guy literally all
tucked away and that little grape
smuggler and he wears.
There was a guy in my class that used to
go there for awhile.
He used to wear the grape smuggler.
He was very sot nom.
He was very.
You hit a man Bun,
two smugglers and Amanda and I want to
pick you up in the parking lot.
Totally.
And I think the other women look at you
over there and your Nike workout stuff
and they're like,
alright,
he's peace vine.
They think so.
Yeah.
They like.
Thank you for not doing that.
I hope so.
I don't know.
The place I go to is very nice.
Very nice people.
Yeah.
But again,
it's not like the hot young hard,
but I'm probably the best looking girl
in the class.
A road.
That was a joke.
I couldn't help it.
That's not true either.
There's some cute ones,
but the point being is that's not what
it is.
It's a,
you know,
but there is a sexual vibe there.
I mean you're just there to do yoga,
but there is that kind of thing,
which is why I'm not too big a fan of
the classes.
The team you up where they want you to
partner up for this thing.
Yeah.
You ever have that?
No.
Oh,
like you stretch you out.
You got to get a partner,
get unhappy baby.
With your legs behind,
your partner pushed down on you and
you're like,
you know,
farther on this lady happens.
That'd be actually the smartphone as a
married man,
that would be the smart man.
How much porn takes place in the Yoga
Student Yoga Studio where the yoga
teacher says,
I would like to review some poses with
you after class to give you some tips.
That'd be like if you were,
let's,
let's just be as politically correct
about this possible.
If you were single and the person
actually was into you and this all went
down according to this,
this,
that would be the greatest like fantasy
ever.
Like you're in that hot yoga class,
all hot and Sweaty,
and afterwards the teacher wants to
fuck.
Damn.
She's like,
Tom,
I just really feel like your practice
could aid with just a little private one
on one instruction.
Yes.
He'd be like,
sure,
sure.
First we're gonna start with a foot
massage.
Okay.
You're back.
Your right.
Oh,
okay.
And she's rubbing your feet and lifting
your legs.
I'm just going to stretch your legs out
and she's rubbing the inside of your
thighs and you start moaning.
She moans back and the next thing you
know it's on top.
Oh,
now my stay.
I had a massage at the Bacara resort and
Santa Barbara.
Oh Shit.
And The lady got up on the table,
like straddled me on the table like at
one point and it just,
you know,
I'm always thinking,
is it going to go someplace else?
It didn't.
But when I came back to the room and
told my wife what had happened,
she was horrified.
She angry.
She was like that.
That does not happen ever.
She was obviously doing something.
I'm like,
she wasn't.
Well,
I mean,
time massage,
they do it all the time.
They jump up on top of it.
Oh yeah,
they climb on you right.
This lady,
I go to,
this bitch fucks me up when I say bitch,
she's a very nice lady.
I shouldn't say bitch.
She's probably in her at least late
fifties,
maybe early sixties.
And she's from Thailand.
Very nice lady.
She climbs on my back.
She pulls my arms up right.
She's stomping on me like she stomped
the shit out of me.
She fucking,
she gets her knee in my back,
brines in the elbows,
feet.
This wasn't that what?
She's always.
She's always asking me,
you'll care this.
Okay.
Come on.
Just go crazy.
I'm fine.
Just do it.
Hurt me.
Go get nutty.
Do everything.
You feel like you need to deal with anti
vegf.
This a.
She just fucking climbs on top of that
table and just jacks me.
There's a lot of comedians in New York
who get the massage lady to come over to
their house.
To Jack.
Jack,
you're talking about Jim Norton.
You don't have to say a lot of
comedians.
You could just say Jim Norton,
Jim Norton and the outer electrons that
spawn from Jimmy and the other guys who
go,
you could do that.
And the other one to get the number from
the chat doesn't seem smart to me.
I talked to Jim about in these ones.
Yeah.
But I had more of my house.
They,
you know,
they,
uh,
I have a security building.
They can't get inside.
I go,
but they know where you live now.
Like what if they develop some bizarre
fixation on you from the radio show and
then meet you after John Lennon style
outside your door?
I don't think there's any part of that
scenario that he doesn't like show me
say.
I think also,
you know,
you're,
you're dipping into the world of people
who get paid for sex and there's not
necessarily a bad world.
The,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it.
I don't think it's unnecessary world.
For some people.
There's nothing wrong with Jerkins
someone off.
It's like,
why is it okay to rub someone's back,
but it's not okay to rub their dick.
You tell me.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's foolishness,
right?
You know the only thing I mean,
I guess the possible threat of diseases,
but if as long as you know proper gun
control,
you know the aim that thing away from
you always makes sure he pointed in a
safe distance and keep the safety on
your fine and stand at least an inch and
a half away and don't put it near your
eyes.
Don't open your eyes up.
I don't know if it's Ms Dot.
No,
I've never been to one of those places
where you know it's going to happen.
I've never been in a place where it
never happened.
I need to talk to Brian Redman.
He'll hook you up,
but you kind of hope I never want to go
to the point of like,
Oh yeah,
actually going there,
but you go to like the straight place at
like a nice resort and stuff and it's
always in the back of your mind like
maybe.
But no.
Yeah,
I've never had a place do it,
but I,
I have gone to a place where one of the
guys that works there,
I got busted because he was blowing all
the dudes that would come in there.
Like they figured out that these gay
guys like flamboyantly gay guys were
coming to this one guy.
They would be like super excited to see
him like a little too excited.
Right.
And he had this little thing going on.
He would have these guys show up and he
would give them like,
you know,
half decent massage,
suck their dick.
And then get out of their fucking
Gideon,
get a big tip,
but problem with those flamboyant gay
guys is they're very vocal.
They like to talk about right now.
That was the best massage I've ever
seen.
I'm sure they had a nickname for him and
for the place.
Well,
you know,
I guess just the word got out,
but you know,
to think that I was getting a legitimate
massage just a few doors over.
Wasn't there a movie sister?
Wasn't there a movie star that got in
trouble for trying to.
John Travolta.
Sexual advancement,
right.
John Travolta.
Digital budgets.
Volta.
Yeah.
He would.
He would get massages and like their
hands.
Yes.
Up into their.
What's going on over there?
Oh,
that's a good time in that area.
Opening it up.
Where's my keys?
Look for my phone.
Did you see him in Oj?
I've met him.
You know in the Oj show?
No.
All the new show on Fx just started last
week.
Oh,
come on.
It's so good.
Is it in the worst way?
No,
it's good.
It's good.
A good show.
It's going to be.
It's a 10 part series.
I think it's actually good Oj versus the
people versus Oj.
Legit.
Good.
Oh,
I thought you were saying it's good.
Like it's retarded and like should watch
it because it's bad.
And Travolta plays Kardashians.
Now.
Robert Shapiro.
Did they shave his head?
Creepy.
Cool.
That's Shapiro.
Wasn't Shapiro Bald guys?
Kind of flamboyant.
Oh,
I'm thinking I'm confusing Robert
Shapiro with f Lee Baily,
but I don't think any job this,
this thing is you think like you're
tapped out on Oj.
Like why would I watch one episode and
you're like,
Oh man,
this is going to be John Travolta.
Jose.
Good.
Wonderful Wig.
He does that is just get in close on
that hairline.
Jamie.
That is impeccable.
That is really nice.
This poor bastard.
I was at a store the other day and this
poor bastard in front of me had one of
the worst things I've ever seen in my
life.
I really say don't full on wig.
It was ridiculous.
It was just ridiculous.
20 16 wig.
Oh my God.
Have you seen Mickey Rourke now?
Oh God,
that's perfect.
We're going to have fucking heroin.
It's incredible.
It's on again tonight.
You'll like it [inaudible] he plays.
You could definitely see him trying to
put his rump and massage therapist
hands.
Could see it.
Yeah.
He seems fairly gay while he's doing it.
Really?
Yo.
He's.
Yeah.
He's playing this very erudite.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Good,
good.
Really,
really good.
Okay.
Dude,
I'm on episode eight of 'em Narchos.
There's only tell.
Yeah,
I finished episode eight last night.
I'm depressed that there's two left.
Really bad.
So good.
Wow.
It's so good.
Pablo Escobar was a mother fucker.
Really?
He built his own fucking jail.
He turned himself into his own jail.
He built his own.
He made a deal with the government,
with the Colombian government where he
would admit to.
This is all historical.
Who says this is the historical fact box
taken from wikipedia.
I actually knew about this in advance,
but I just didn't know how they were
going to play it out on the show,
but he did a fantastic job in the show,
but he turned himself.
I mean,
he was a fucking major league drug
dealer.
The greatest drug dealer of all time.
Next to El Chapo.
El Chapo was apparently even a bigger
deal than him really,
but he made it so that he would only get
charged with one count of smuggling
drugs.
And even then he wanted a bargain that
down to a lesser charge.
He built his own super powerful luxury
prison,
had his own guards to guard him and this
super powerful
luxury prison cheese.
And that's where it was in Columbia,
in Columbia.
So the government,
they had um,
oh well he killed everybody and,
but they had him now and he's like,
I even have them nailed.
He turned himself in.
He was just killing everybody.
She really killed,
blew up planes,
just killed everybody.
She's just killed thousands of people.
I mean he had all these sicario is
apparently that was what they call a
hitman Spanish.
He just had all these hitman's killing
cops,
killing everybody,
killing judges.
He,
they,
they even had all this evidence about
him dealing drugs.
So he hired this like a communist sort
of revolutionary group to overtake the
government building where his data was
being held and blew it up,
lit it on fire,
lit up all this fucking evidence.
We took over a fucking government
building.
Like,
oh well we can house.
It was insane.
It's insane story.
He's still alive.
He's dead as fuck.
He's dead.
You have to get them.
I'm going to have to watch your show.
I'm watching Oj.
It was a shootout,
if I remember correctly from rival gang
or the government.
I think the government shot him.
Wow.
Who?
Who shot him?
Jeremy Pablo was uh,
was caring,
caring so much.
I was earning so much each year they
read off 10 percent of the money because
the rats would eat it in storage or be
damaged by water.
And Lost Mike.
That would be about two point 1 billion.
So two point 1 billion per month,
per month was what?
The rats?
No,
it says here,
it says each year picture right above
it.
Said it was factored in.
A two point 1 billion loss in profits
each month.
Well,
scroll that down.
Last.
The loss was to what it says it was.
It was earning so much.
Each year he'd write off 10 percent.
That would be to write 10 percent per
year.
She's $420 million a week.
Look at his face to look at.
I'm happy.
Fuck.
Happy Dude.
Yes.
Happy to do so much money.
So much money.
I always wonder what these guys eat for
dinner.
Whatever the fuck they want babies.
What's he saying?
Chinese babies around 6:00
at night.
Who was he talking to?
That was the big shows up.
That picture did him in because that was
one of the earliest pictures of him
getting arrested.
He got arrested and they will any.
He was smiling at them like,
you dumb fucks.
You didn't get an arrest me and then
just wrecked havoc on the people that
arrested him.
He just.
It was amazing,
man.
Amazing.
So the show's great.
He wants started a fire with $2,000,000
because his daughter was cold for real
man.
Wow.
It was.
What years was this?
It looks like eighties.
Nineties.
This is the fucking cocaine years,
right?
What his is this subtle scarface.
Wow.
His son who's 30,
he's 38 years old since changed his
name.
Describe what life was like on the run
with Sebastian Maniscalco,
if that makes sense.
Jesus always ducking fucking.
It's unbelievable story and it's so
well done that show narcos.
Netflix is killing it.
They're so good right now.
So good.
There's a house of cards that mean
making a murderer.
Oh,
I haven't seen that yet.
That one's pretty good.
I haven't seen you will give it getting
mad at me because I haven't seen it.
You know that one around eight a guy and
you're like,
all right,
let's wrap this up.
I'll really like.
You're kind of like push them through
like one more set Sunday night.
I want him to agree to a late show on
Sunday.
Right?
Exactly the funny fuck face in the
middle of nowhere.
Did you see soaked in bleach?
No.
That is the documentary that was created
with the help of the private
investigator.
The Courtney love hired,
who actually believes that she had Kurt
cobain killed.
She hired the private investigator,
hired the private investigator to find
him during the time that he was missing
and blah,
blah,
blah.
During his interactions with her,
he believed her to be so deceptive and
such a liar and a manipulator,
and then the evidence that he presents,
he believes is enough to reopen the
case.
He said they did a terrible job of
examining the body.
They,
they,
they cremated them within six days.
The police called it a suicide,
not an autopsy specialists,
which is just not the way you do it.
And he said there's enough evidence to
point to that.
He and his words thinks that courtney
love had Kurt cobain killed for the
money because he was leaving her.
I
had him killed.
Yeah,
or helped him,
helped him kill himself.
They said that the amount of cocaine or
heroin or that was in his body was three
times the lethal dose.
But of course that means for me,
that was never done heroin,
but like was it for him?
The guy who did heroin all the time,
that other documentary with all the
doodles moving around.
She see that one.
What's that one with all the doodles?
Yeah.
They took all of his notebooks.
Montage of heck yeah,
I haven't seen that one.
There's a couple of scenes where they
show them,
you know,
blitzed out on heroin and oh really?
It's too bad.
Drugs are bad.
So bad.
I mean just wasted with this kid.
Like his little kid is right there and
like her birthday,
something like that.
Oh,
that's so sad.
He's just in another planet.
Bad,
bad drug.
I used to know a guy or a serious heroin
problem,
but he was like a world class pool
player.
Oh yeah.
And he would get heroin down and then we
play pool and he,
he wouldn't miss.
He had no nerves and he would be playing
my friend George the Greek,
not like the famous George,
the Greek,
the racist guy.
Although this guy was probably racing
right?
Jimmy,
the Greek.
Jimmy the Greek,
right.
My friend George degree,
he would talk like,
this is fucking cock sucker and a ga
Greek would be so mad because he would
gamble with this guy and the guy's name
was water dog.
They would call me the buffalo bill or
water dog.
There's two nicknames.
Both cool names.
This guy used to go to the bathroom.
He would lock the door in the men's room
and executive billiards in white plains,
New York.
He would go in there and lock the
bathroom door and then come out 10
years,
10 years,
10 years later to him,
but 10 minutes later we'd come out just
whacked out of his mind.
He was sitting in a bar stool like this.
He would sit down and he would have his
arms like on the rest is risk.
Would just hang there like his hands
gently rest on his gut,
his hands and just sit there and he
would just zone out for like another 20
minutes and then he would get up and be
good.
He would get up and he had like shark
eyes.
His eyes were like black,
like his pupils were totally dilated and
he would get up and he would screw
together as cute.
There's a photo of him,
you could find it online.
Buffalo bill or water dog,
a pool player.
Um,
I forget his real name,
but anyway,
he screwed together as kill and he
wouldn't fucking miss and they were
playing on this table with these really
tiny tight pockets.
It was a gambler's tables table one at
executive billiards and they were
playing for thousands of dollars and you
know,
that's a fucking lot of pressure.
I didn't feel a thing.
He was just dead on the inside.
Just gone from how long will last?
It was good for hours,
hours like that?
Yeah.
How many years?
Oh,
he's dead.
He's dead now.
He died a few years back.
What were you doing?
Shooting Pool in white plains.
Twice to live.
I used to live in white plains,
new Rochelle.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I bought,
I got an apartment in new Rochelle
because it was close to executive
billiards in white plains.
Really?
Yeah,
it's great.
I was there,
but so often my manager thought that I
had a problem.
He's like,
do you taken pool more seriously than
your career?
My God,
I might be just so much fun.
The people that are hung out with were
so fun.
Really?
Mount Vernon,
Tommy international style.
I'll hang out with a guy who was an
international credit card smuggler.
He was the first really,
his name is international style and
international south was a.
He was a Gambler,
but I use that word loosely because he
was an incredible loser,
but he made so much money from all this
credit card swindled that he would go
into the pool hall.
This is before my time before I met him.
I met him once.
He got out of jail,
but he was still a loser.
He just couldn't win.
Right.
Psychologically he had like these
blocks,
like he would have a ball like sitting
in front of the whole for a thousand
dollars and he just bumped because
bobble it.
He could never win.
He'd never won.
He never.
He was just psychology.
It's a weird thing.
It was crazy.
So during the time where he was a
swindler,
what he would do is,
this was the early days of credit cards.
This is the 19 eighties American
Express.
They would take these receipts that they
would get them from stores,
like say if they run your credit card on
something.
Yeah.
They get that.
The carbons,
they would get those carbons and then
they would make copies of the credit
card,
they make another copy of the credit
card and just fucking run up these crazy
bills by all this shit and then sell the
shit.
And so he would get money and they would
come to the pool hall was just Brown
paper bags filled with hundred dollar
bills and people from all over the world
would come to find him to play with
them.
Really?
Yeah.
Because he was a loser because he was a
loser with tons and tons of cash.
So he would just lose all of it.
And I say he's a loser.
I don't mean like as a person who was a
very nice guy,
but I mean like as a pool player,
he was a loser.
She wasn't a bad player either,
but like good enough to play.
But the big games player,
he psychologically was a beat,
a beat man.
He just could not do it.
Did he drink?
Um,
nope.
No,
I don't believe he did.
Uh,
he died of cancer and it was an ugly one
to.
My friend's mom was a,
the,
one of the nurses that was taking care
of them and it was just,
it ended bad,
but they're all dead.
All those people that I really like.
Then yeah,
the guy who owned it,
guy as red and he was just fucking
hilarious piano players,
musician.
I wanted to invest his money and he
bought a pool hall and it just became
this incredible hangout because she's
this guy guy as a reedy who owned it was
the nicest guy on the planet and
everybody loved them.
So they would come and hang out at his
pool hall,
like partially just to say hi and hang
out with him.
And then he created this incredible
environment.
It was like all fun and laughs.
And did you know other comics sit there?
Just one.
There was one.
This Guy Jon Tobin who was a buddy of
mine at the time,
he was a,
he worked there part time Gig.
They're like the counterman for a little
bit,
but no,
it was mostly just pool players.
Me and a bunch of pool players,
it's pretty cool.
Degenerates and Weirdos and it's pretty
cool that you had the balls to just go
hang out there with all these crack.
Well,
I became addicted to pool.
When I became addicted to pool,
it was like that was my spot.
I was there every night and I knew a lot
of the people that worked there and ran
it and guy the owner was a good friend
of mine so we would be there oftentimes
till the morning and then we'd get up.
We'd go to the diner and this was.
I was 24 or 20 somewhere around there,
so I had no job.
My job was to do jokes,
so do jokes.
At night I would.
I would literally,
I would get up and go to the gym.
I'd had over the pool hall.
I'd hang out,
see what's going on.
Then I would go do my gig and then I'd
come back to the pool hall and I'd stay
there until the morning.
Where would you go gig?
Wherever it was either in the city or a
lot of the gigs that I did.
When I first moved to New York,
I used to do that,
a danger fields.
I did the comic strip.
I did all those.
I did catch.
That's when cash was still there at
catch,
a rising star was still there.
But um,
I didn't like the fact that I only did
10 minutes and then it wasn't any money,
so I was doing a lot of Connecticut
gigs.
So this Guy John Schuler,
do you ever do those Connecticut cakes?
And.
I don't think so.
John Schuller,
he kept me paid.
That name's familiar.
It was great.
Great Guy.
Yeah.
He had a bunch of good gigs.
They were solid Connecticut,
you know,
a hotel lounge bar and had a nice little
stage.
But there was Jersey gigs.
I did a lot of those for this guy.
Bob Gonzo Gonzo.
Yeah.
Know Him.
Yeah,
I think it did a couple like out in
summit,
New Jersey or something like that.
Yeah,
the shore.
I did those with him and um,
I did um,
with auto and George,
we did a bunch of those there.
And then I did a decided Connecticut
Jersey Long Island did a lot of long
island gigs,
the brokerage governors.
But so is the thing that made you set up
shop there?
Yeah,
that was going to the city couldn't
afford the city,
couldn't afford parking.
Right.
I knew that.
I enjoyed your car.
I needed a car.
I had a car and I wasn't gonna get rid
of it.
So it was like,
okay,
I can't afford an apartment.
Like apartments for people were out of
the country or out of the city.
New York City apartment rates are so
insane that it doesn't make sense that
anybody could afford to live there other
than rich people.
And it's gotten so much worse from back
then way worse way than it was.
You couldn't achieve it.
Now forget it.
Well,
I was poor as fuck you mean back then
when I first moved there,
I lived with my grandfather and north
ninth street in Newark,
New Jersey,
which was the ghetto.
My grandfather art got it in the 19
forties and when it was an all Italian
neighborhood and then it became an all
black neighborhood.
And then it became Puerto Rican,
then it became Dominican and production
left and just dried up.
Also,
they did blockbusting where the real
estate people would,
uh,
come door to door and they would say,
hey,
black people are moving in,
you know,
you've got to sell now.
Otherwise you're,
your property value's going to go
through the floor.
And they would literally clean out whole
blocks like that.
And Salomon people would sell their
houses in a panic.
No.
Yeah.
Really?
Yeah,
they did to my grandfather.
And like,
I liked black people.
Get the fuck Outta here.
He wouldn't move.
He stayed there to the end.
Yeah,
it was,
it was crazy.
Yeah.
There was a common tactic that they used
to use.
Find a picture of that guy.
So dirty kind of started getting
distracted about Mike Segal.
No,
no,
no.
Mike Segal is a famous world champion.
This guy's name was buffalo bill.
That is what they used to call them,
pool player Gambler or water dot.
But he was.
So did you find weird looking guy?
Did you know of the pool hall?
And then say,
let me try and find a place near here or
to the other way around.
No,
I was living in New Jersey when my
grandfather was trying to save up enough
money to get an apartment and when I
saved up enough money to get an
apartment,
um,
I was taking the trek down to white
plains all the time as my friend John
and my friend Johnny B,
who was Johnny B was actually a
professional pool hustler who's like,
one of my best friends became one of my
best friends at around that same town
about.
But it was a special place man.
I've thought about almost writing a book
about the adventures of being a part of
that place because it was so fun.
I was just going to say,
I think I've been in la too long because
I,
the whole time you're like,
this is a great movie or show was.
It was like a movie.
It was like every night there was
something going on there and we would
run to get to that place.
Wow.
I couldn't wait to get in there.
You get in the door and no one had a
phone back then because there was a,
there was a cell phone or a payphone,
payphone.
People would be on the phone all the
time,
like getting calls.
It would ring and people would call and
so no one had,
no one had cell phones but people would
come in from all over the country
because that was a place that will have
gambling action.
So guys would come in from Canada,
guys would come in,
California,
a guy came in from there,
they can come in from all over the place
playing but not at that level.
Oh No,
I wasn't good.
You're just playing,
you know,
I was more of a spectator.
I was playing and I was playing in
tournaments and stuff like that and I
got.
I got better over the couple of years
that I lived there,
but I was never at a level that these
guys were at.
These are like real professional level
players would go there.
And is it like any sport,
like those guys just had something
special or they just put more time in
time?
Yeah,
I think.
I think there are special,
there's certain special things like
athleticism,
like Karl Malone or like a Michael
Jordan or know fill in the blanks with
some of the elite athletes.
Lebron,
Lebron James,
and you use your regular guy at yoga.
Yeah.
You're a regular guy.
He's not.
There's a giant advantage is a giant
advantage.
He has that thing and then on top of
that,
I think when you get a guy like Lebron
James,
but you get as a guy who has this
massive physical advantage and then
dedication and then intelligence and
then discipline and then you get a great
one.
It's once in a lifetime athlete that
comes along that has the whole package,
but we'll pull.
It's not like that because there's no
physical strength aspect of it.
Long arms.
Nope.
Doesn't help at all.
Some of the best players in the world.
Really tiny guys.
Are they really using the bridge?
Well,
there are other switch hands switch.
They play lefthanded like Jose Perico
was like one of the greatest players of
all time.
He's like five one.
Oh really?
Tiny little Filipino guy.
Yeah,
so it's just more just dedication and
time and dedication,
the implant,
understanding of geometry,
angles,
understanding like how the ball's gonna
reflect off other balls and it's going
to bounce off the rail.
Things along those lines.
So you got good though.
I got pretty good.
Yeah.
I never got real good.
I got it.
I got good compared to regular people.
Regular people see me play the like,
Holy Shit.
He's like a pool player would never be
impressed.
Now I'm okay that game with like,
I don't think there are pockets.
Three cushioned billiards.
Three different balls.
And they were,
yeah,
you hit one ball and it has to go three
cushions and then hit the other bowl.
It's a weird game.
Yeah.
That's a game that's really popular in
South America.
Really popular in Korea.
Korea town.
You can go to Korea town.
They have three cushioned billiards
places.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I was a St Lucia or someplace like that
and they had a table there and no one
knew what they were doing.
Yeah,
there's a,
we used to have one,
um,
that,
uh,
they set up an executive and people from
like all these other kinds of,
like,
a lot of Mexican players would come in.
Guys who worked in the area who were,
um,
Latino from some Latin American
countries,
they'd come,
they'd be so happy to find a table like
that.
Really.
Isn't it weird how some games just can
last centuries?
Yeah.
Like chess [inaudible] pool,
bace,
you know what I mean?
Like there's something to.
They just got it right.
Yeah.
That it could last that long chest isn't
weird thing and amazing one in that
regard because there's never been a
game.
It's really come along.
That's become the,
uh,
any sort of a contender for the
intellectual game.
Right.
That is the intellectual.
Yeah.
And it's to ship made a run at it.
You know,
chess is sick.
It's also one game.
It's one of the few games where you
could tell people you play and they
don't look at you like you're wasting
your time.
Know you're right.
That's exactly right.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
Like even pool.
I got to tell people I love to play
pool.
Right,
exactly.
Get home to your family,
right?
You tell people you're involved in a
chess tournament.
You're like,
wow,
he's a dedicated into electrical.
Tom.
Papa.
Papa thinks it really is true.
Yeah.
I wish I knew more people.
We played chess.
I wish my,
I tried to get my daughter's into it,
but uh,
it's a cool thing to be able to do.
Just so engrossing.
Good for your mind.
Yeah.
There was a guy,
I was on a movie once and the guy was
renting his house out for you.
Ever seen how they do that?
Like people rent their house out for
movies.
Yeah.
I used to know a guy,
that's how I paid his whole mortgage.
She had a cool house in the Hollywood
hills and he just rented out to movie
studios and TV studios and that's how he
paid his bills and they would only use
it like a couple of days a month and
that paid for everything.
But anyway,
this guy was a chess player and all he
did was play chess really?
So we're hanging around with this guy
and his house and I'm like,
so you just played chess?
He was like,
yeah,
I play chess and I,
I,
you know,
I'm divorced so I don't need the whole
house.
I rent the house out for movies and just
kind of fun.
I like watching movies,
get filmed in my house.
I'm like,
wow,
that's crazy because you had to kind of
a cool house.
And so I went with them and like,
show me what you do.
He goes,
okay,
well I'm about to get a game right now,
so I'll go to this forum and I'll say
who would like to have a game?
And then they meet up in this room and
then they play chess online.
Online.
Yeah.
And I was watching him play chess online
and that's apparently where the majority
of games get played.
Norton and I were starting to do that.
You could play against each other
online.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And uh,
it's cool,
but there's,
I just the physical part,
it's like anything with online
newspapers,
whatever.
I missed the physical moving the pieces.
Yeah.
But yeah,
he was into it for for a bit.
Howard stern was into it to the point
where he was taking lessons talking
about it on the air all the time.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I think he probably decided it was just
a mad.
I mean he's,
it's a time suck.
Yeah,
And once I started being able to read in
the paper the moves and understand it,
I was like,
I'm spending too much time.
I would say that's what I'm fucking
balling me.
I'm so smart.
Oh,
King took six course.
The obvious Belgium variation.
Why is it in the paper?
Because it's fucking smart people.
It's like,
it's like reading the box score to a
baseball game.
Well,
it's always been in the paper.
That particular game that someone's
playing that you're following along,
they're showing,
you know,
these two guys just played last night in
this big tournament or whatever.
Well maybe.
Has there ever been a newspaper that
it'll show a move then ask you for the
counter to that move and then you like,
you play the game out day after day?
No,
no.
They want it to do it,
but then,
uh,
the Sukkot people blocked it.
The word find people were outraged.
What was the,
the,
uh,
conspiracy that we were talking about
before the podcast started?
That we both thought was bullshit that
you,
you brought up.
Oh yeah.
The chipolte lay bullet thing.
Yeah.
What's the chipotle?
A conspiracy as I was eating chipotle a
on this wacky diet.
Man I can be doing now.
Any grains.
I'm on this.
It's called the primal blueprint diet.
And the idea behind it as no grains,
no car,
like very low carbohydrates,
no sugar,
no processed sugar.
You can have like a piece of fruit every
now and then,
but you wanted to bring your body into
ketosis where your body burns off fat
and everybody's doing.
Everybody's telling me not to do it.
Go.
This will work for this.
I'm like,
have you done it?
No,
but shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up.
Where did you hear about it?
We'll have this guy on.
His name's Mark Sisson.
He's a pretty famous guy in the Paleo
community.
He,
the,
you know your term Paleolithic Diet?
Yeah.
Well,
that's actually kind of bullshit.
Yeah.
Well,
what's bullshit is Paleolithic people
didn't really eat like that.
They they brands.
So what he's saying is like,
the name is wrong,
but the diet,
the principles of the Diet are really
good for fighting inflammation for a lot
of people.
Like he had irritable bowel syndrome.
A lot of people,
they find that it helps them with
arthritis and a lot of it cures a lot of
inflammatory issues.
Not that I have them,
but I'm like,
okay,
well let's see what it's like.
And then I had this Guy Kyle Kingsbury
on who's a former UFC fighter,
great athlete,
Great Guy,
very,
very smart.
And he was talking to me about it and
one of the things that he said was he
was citing the mental clarity aspects of
it.
He said it makes his mind functions
better.
He has more energy.
He feels more even throughout the day.
And then I talked to my car,
my brother Danny protocols,
you know Danny Danny probe,
who,
who's a world champion Jujitsu player,
who's a good friend of mine,
found out that I was doing it and he
said he's been on it since November.
And he also cited the mental clarity
thing,
real and denny's,
a real physical culture wizard.
He's always on top of the latest and
greatest of all the techniques and
modalities as far as training and stuff
like that.
So just no grains is the dominant
fucking grains.
Mostly fats like fats.
Like I eat a lot of Avocados.
I run mighty five,
fucking Avocados a day.
Really?
I had two of these stake bowls from aaa
today with just beans.
No,
no rice.
Just extra heaps of Guacamole.
And then I two giant things of Guacamole
on top of that.
So I'm just eating guacamole.
So steak bowl would have made.
He didn't mention did I said steak bowl.
But then you listed a stake taking it.
But you also took the right?
Yeah.
That just.
No,
just no rice beans set.
I'm just eating boring shit when I go to
the meat.
Is Great,
but when I go to a restaurant could
fucking Lord.
It's hard to find things to eat.
Restaurants kill every diet no matter
what.
No matter what you're trying to do,
restaurants are just bad place.
I went to this one place and I wanted to
get a nice salad and then I said,
wait a minute.
What's in the salad dressing?
Do you toss it in the side?
Yeah,
it comes already tossed in it.
You might as well be eating candy,
right?
The side.
I'm like,
this is crazy.
I can't even eat this.
I go,
this is all sugar.
And like,
well there is some sugar and I go,
what?
Some of the fucking desert.
Your Salads.
Goddamn desert.
It was glistening with syrup.
I'm not kidding.
I know,
I know.
That stuff's high calorie.
You have wood ranch.
Every wood ranch,
barbecue places,
they have this thing called a natalie
salads.
Fucking delicious.
I love it,
but he might as well be eating an ice
cream Sundae.
It's a salad that's discovered in syrup.
She's their salad dressing is syrup.
So how long have you been doing this
diet?
Today is,
what is it,
Jamie Day nine,
nine.
I think.
I didn't have days.
I feel great.
I know I've lost a little weight,
which uh,
you know,
my body's always pretty much the same
weight really gain or lose,
but I did some things in the past that
made me lose weight.
One of them was I cut all the sugar out
of my diet.
I lost five pounds in a week,
like doing nothing else but doing that
really it was crazy.
And then I went gluten free for a while
and that,
that helped me a lot.
That made me feel like there was
something going on to that,
like a energy levels felt good.
My skin look good,
like really healthy.
I think what that is though is the sugar
thing,
because I think with gluten,
gluten is bread and pasta in Wheaton.
That stuff,
it's not like I had an issue with gluten
itself,
like I didn't have an issue processing
gluten.
Right?
It's all converts to sugar,
right?
Like that's just a lot of sugar for your
body and your body just doesn't want
that much sugar to process this
essentially toxic and the more people
are learning about sugar,
the more people are coming to an
agreement like almost all these
scientists and nutritional experts that
come to an agreement like processed
sugar is just fucking awful.
It's brutal.
It's really bad and it's in everything.
Everything.
I've been baking bread lately.
Holy Shit.
Sourdough bread.
Sourdough bread is very good for you.
It is.
Has Gluten though.
Natural process.
Yeah,
but sour dough bread apparently has way
less gluten than regular bread right
here because my wife can eat that
mechanic.
The other brand really?
It's a cool thing.
It just takes the.
You just take flour and water.
You need a starter,
which is culture.
Yeah.
You just start with flour and water and
the natural yeast that comes from around
us in the environment goes in and starts
eating that.
What?
And it becomes a living thing and people
have starters that are like 100 years
old wax you take,
you take a couple ounces off and you
always maintain a little and feed it
like a living thing.
It's like a bowl of flour and water,
but it's,
you'll see it start to bubble when you
feed it more flour and water receding.
Yeah,
it's the coolest.
That's crazy.
So it's in your refrigerator.
In my fridge.
Oh,
a little little.
A Mason Jar.
And then you scoop it out,
you take a little chunk of it in the
feed it and it expands.
And then you take some of that and make
bread out of it.
That is fucking nuts.
It's pretty.
Yeah.
So never would have been into this if I
didn't hear that concept.
And now I can stop baking bread,
like Little Red Riding Hood.
Who gave you the idea to do this?
This writer friend of mine,
he's been doing it for a long time and
he said it's just,
you just have sourdough bread and the
kids love it.
And Wow.
I just started doing it and uh,
I just got hooked on it.
Where do you buy your starter?
You don't buy it.
You can just start it.
You make a starter,
make a starter.
Okay.
How do you do that?
You just take some flour and water and
put it out on the,
on the,
uh,
counter.
That's it.
Yeah.
I mean there's measurements and stuff,
but that's it.
And then the natural yeast,
there's yeast around us just floating
around that explains a lot of things.
The APP and it goes into,
it goes into the,
uh,
into the concoction and you'll see it
starts to bubble and get lighter and you
feed it some more and it gets bigger.
When you say feed it like for you,
because it's,
it's like a yeast,
a little,
like a little community feeding you
equal parts of flour and water.
Wow.
And it eats it and now it's like this
living thing in the house who has a star
that's 100 years old.
I went to buy a Dutch oven,
which is like a pot that you can bake
that we put the bread in and this old
guy was like,
what are you doing?
Even the guy will sit down with like six
foot lanky.
What do you need it for?
I'm like,
I'm going to make some bread.
Oh,
I've been making bread for a long time.
Really?
I'm going to be making sourdough bread.
Oh,
I got my start and where are you getting
your starter?
I said,
well,
a friend of mine has the brightest
starter and my daughter.
What labrea?
What's the labrea starter?
That one is that all the brave labrea
bakery bread.
You get the yeast off of the skin of
grapes,
so he is a process where you take grapes
and you put it in like cheesecloth and
you just let the.
The yeast come off of all,
all grapes have yeast in the skin,
eating on the skin of the grapes and
that drips off and then you put it into
the basic.
Started with flour and water.
So it have you say liberal,
sweeter say chain.
Is that what you mean?
Like liberal,
yeah,
there's,
you'll see them there are actual bakery
and now they're like in Ralph's and
everything that's all over and they say,
and like the places San Francisco that
have big sourdough,
that it all,
it's maintains the same.
Started that they've always had.
So this guy said,
uh,
so I told them where I was getting my
stuff,
my daughter made one as a gift and then
this other guy gave me a piece.
He said his starter came from Jackson
Hole,
Wyoming and he got it from a friend of
his and it's over 100 years old.
People have been passing it on to cowboy
starter.
Cowboy started.
That's what it was.
It was a lot of miners in San Francisco
and all that.
During the gold rush they were creating
bred that way.
That's where it started.
Yeah.
I wonder how old the yeast organisms get
before they die and do they die?
They probably reproduce in.
Yeah.
It's a good question.
I don't know because basically like I
have it on my counter nab and feeding it
for the last day,
so now,
so now it's kind of bubbly.
Wow.
It's like glue and it's kind of bubbly,
so I'll scoop out four ounces of that,
make bread out of it,
and then take one ounce of that,
put it back in the jar,
feed it a little and put it in the
fridge.
So what's the process?
So if you took four ounces out and made
bread with it,
what do you do with that?
The starter,
uh,
you basically take a lot of flour.
You take like 28,
this is to make two of them two loaves.
You take a,
a 28 ounces of all purpose flour or
wheat flour,
whatever you want to use.
You put that in with a little salt.
Then you take your starter,
you take the four ounces and an 18
ounces of water,
a bunch of water,
and you make it into a cloudy mixture.
And then you dump that into the flour
and salt that's in your mixer and it
just makes it into dough.
And then it just rises naturally.
Bold it a couple times,
put it into a ball,
into the Dutch oven after a couple of
hours,
and then you've got bread.
It's that simple.
How long before you start growing your
own wheat and smashing up with a rock?
Probably I'm.
I'm headed that way.
That is where the guy who worry about
the Dutch oven
from is like,
I really like seed breads and then I
looked it up.
That's like crazy.
Like 12 different seeds from different
places and you mash them up and then
you're getting a job at Williams sonoma.
I went to the Museum of natural history.
They have a,
an Egyptian mummy display.
Really fucking cool.
Yeah,
but one of the interesting things was by
the time Egyptian people were older,
you know,
they didn't leave that live that long,
but if they did,
they didn't have any teeth left because
the way they made bread,
they grounded up.
They ground up their own flour and it
left sand in the bread.
So the bread was all you were eating,
sand were away your teeth.
That's gross.
I thought you were going to say sugar.
No sand.
Oh,
wear your teeth down time.
The down Arabs.
And they had all these methods that they
were trying to concoct to save teeth,
like wooden caps,
that they would put a shoe on that
instead of chewing with whatever nerve
endings were left in your face,
just so you could eat more.
Sam Breads Sandy Bread fucked.
Oh,
it is a kind of a trippy thing that you
just put some flour and water and this
yeast comes from the environment and now
you've got this amazing tasting bread
that the family can't stop eating.
The kids cutting it.
It's just has been around for ever right
out of the oven when it's.
We're eating bread like crazy.
Like when you're talking about like
eating sugar and all that flat.
We just can't stop.
Wow.
We're all going to be fun.
I'm going the other way.
I'm not eating any of it.
At least for 60 days I'm going to.
I don't feel.
I don't feel mentally clear.
Have you made some life choices they
regret?
I told you I woke up at seven this
morning.
Like,
oh,
I got to do a show tonight.
And that's the bread is the bread is
bread.
It's making me.
Laying you down.
So weird man.
Yeah.
So weird that you could just like put it
out there and the natural yeast grows.
I had no idea.
I felt like it.
You know what I wish someone had asked
me where does it come from because I
never considered it before.
I would have been like a fucking.
What is it?
A plant.
What is,
I don't know.
And then there's like,
you know,
because you can buy yeast that just make
regular bread and you throw it in there
and it eats wow.
Own maintains a hundred and 22 year old
sourdough starter.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Whoa.
There was a woman on line who's this?
Radical feminists who made sourdough
bread out of her pussy east.
Yeah.
Go find that one.
Jim couldn't keep their hands off it.
Oh,
it was fucking flying off the shelves.
Yeah.
I tweeted about it,
but it was quite awhile ago.
Probably never find it,
but I was like,
good for her.
There is.
I can't tell you.
It's really a weird thing.
I mean,
who haven't never.
I've never be bacon bread.
Now I'm like hooked on it.
Yeah.
There is a woman who made sourdough
bread using yeast from her vagina,
just ate the bread.
Why wouldn't she know I would eat a
donut.
Gross.
Why is it so gross when I eat it?
But when my wife swallows it,
it's all gravy.
That's a good relationship to committed.
So life is built?
Yeah,
it's a compromise.
Yeah.
So I'm baking bread and getting fat.
What else you doing?
Growing?
Anything in your garden?
You one of those guys?
No,
no,
no.
We're surrounded by bamboo.
I hadn't had a bone arrow.
Bamboo just cost me five grand.
What?
Why?
Well,
once we had the reins,
nothing was draining off the property
properly.
So,
uh,
they started looking at the drainage
pipes and stuff.
And the guys who built it didn't
fastened them together at one point.
Oh,
gram bu has grown into.
It's like a log.
I mean,
I never saw it this thick like sign that
just happened.
It's massive.
I had a root growing in my pipe.
CV can find that.
That was online,
like a toilet route.
It looked like a group,
like the guy was pulling a Gofer out of
my toilet.
There was actually,
this is what happened when we moved to
Colorado for a bit.
Um,
I didn't use that bathroom obviously
because we were there for like four
months.
Right.
And so the,
the thing had apparently been in the
toilet.
There it is.
That's from my own bathroom.
That's the bathroom in my office.
Oh my God.
That thing.
This guy is holding it up right now.
I'm sending you.
Is that solid or was that.
Was that fibrous?
What does that flicker can send me that
photo so I can put it up on Instagram,
but because I always forget about this,
I need to put it up somewhere.
Show people.
But that fucking thing it looked like if
you see how thick it is,
it looks like he's pulling a Muskrat
out.
It looks like some kind of a weasel or
something.
How long was it?
Fucking huge.
It's like four feet long.
At least you start to get scared of it.
You're like,
this stuff is really invasive.
Like it could really do some damage.
Oh yeah.
It's not good with this beautiful bread.
Wow.
That's your bread.
It's pretty good.
That's amazing.
That looks excellent.
It's good.
It makes me want to break my diet.
That was like one of my first ones and
this is the starter.
Have you gotten better at it?
Yeah,
fortunately we got to get back on the
road home.
Baking bread.
This is a lot of starter.
Oh,
okay.
Just since before I knew what I was
doing,
I was growing a lot of it.
Now you just need like a little bit.
Was this just like,
do you have a burning desire to do this?
Like,
no,
my friend told me about it,
that he was doing it and I came home at
dinner,
told my wife and kids about it and then
for Christmas my daughter started a
starter.
She went off in youtube and figured out
how to do it and then for her presence
she gave me some starter.
Oh,
that's so cute.
So sweet.
So we started making bread off of that
and then my other friend who turned me
onto it originally,
he brought me a little of the bravest
starter creatures.
Yeah.
Have you thought about experimenting
with different starters,
like the grape starter?
The starter,
the pussy ones.
Intriguing.
I didn't know about it until just now.
That's the show's good for now.
Uh,
it now maybe grow my own weed.
That would be good.
Now it's pretty safe.
Pretty safe to grow.
You don't really get in trouble for
that.
Now.
Fornia,
Texas,
you can go to jail forever.
You can so stupid forever.
They can fucking lock if they found you
with a giant plant that not only that,
like say if you have a plant in the
plants and dirt and the dirt and a pot.
They were the whole thing together.
So if you have a big heavy clay pot at
the end,
the dirt that it goes in,
you might have 50 pounds of weed.
She,
well you really don't even have a pound
of weed.
Oh my God,
that's probably a male class.
I grew it in college.
We had a house and we had like a walk in
closet.
Oh really?
Because the happy days.
Yeah.
Just seeing it come alive and knowing,
you know,
in school you had no money to even buy
it and then we'll all of a sudden we
were growing.
It is great.
That is not to sell just for ourselves.
Good.
Oh,
it was beautiful.
It was beautiful.
That would be a nice thing to grow.
That's a good idea.
Until your kids find it.
Yeah.
Then you got to explain.
I know know daddy's funny and silly.
Daddy's enhanced.
It was natural for awhile,
but now he's got to keep it going with I
knew a guy who had a um,
a dispensary and in the back room of the
dispensary it was a very large room
where they were growing weed and I went
into the room and it was like we'd those
like five feet high,
five foot high plants and all these
lights and everything.
And I swear to God it felt like you were
going into a room filled with people.
Like there was like an intelligence in
that room.
Really very strange.
Really.
Granted I was hiding.
It must have been really when I walked
in there,
but I do really think there's something
to it.
It was something to that room.
I was like,
wow,
this room feels like there's things in
here.
Like it doesn't seem like a room.
Full plant.
Yeah.
Like you can go into a room full of
plants.
You're like,
oh,
this is beautiful vegetation.
Yeah.
But this is like,
you know,
full of hello.
It was very weird that it's like,
I totally get that you really start to
care for them too.
It really seems insane that you don't
own a dispensary.
It's like me and anybody with anybody
with a brain living in California,
it's like you see in,
you know,
Denver print money to change that city
and people are making so much money.
We're talking about going into.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We've considered starting in Denver,
perhaps some sort of an edible factory.
Really hire mercenaries.
What do I got?
You gotta hire mercenaries and I'm not
joking if you want to do that.
It's all cash.
Um,
you're,
you're dealing with a lot of people that
know that this is like essentially like
a bank they can rob,
but it has much less security and for
the longest time people were being
forced to take these cash drops and take
him to banks and banks weren't even
taking them.
So then they would have to take them to
banks and convert them to like a
traveler's check or something along
those lines.
Like there was a bunch of different work
around so they had to.
Some banks do.
Banks are taking it now though.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing
now.
I don't think there's the real issue is
if some fucking Wackadoo like Ted Cruz
actually becomes the president,
which is not outside of the realm of
possibility.
Phillips,
this is one of the scariest elections in
recent memory for me,
I think is the most scary because I
don't think that people are willing to
vote for Hillary Clinton.
I not only do I not think that people
are willing to vote for her.
I think that,
uh,
I don't even think.
I think the people that are willing to
vote for her are only willing to vote
for her because she's a woman and they
go,
let's,
let's see if chicks can do it,
you know,
or I want a woman in office,
Yay.
I get that kind of thing,
but she's not compelling as a leader.
She's just not now.
Now Bernie Sanders is interesting.
He's very interesting.
Socially,
he's very interesting in that he's.
He's just,
he's way more a man of a people of the
people than anybody else.
And people like he's a career
politician.
You.
Yeah,
but this fucking guy is.
He's so different than any other career
politician that's running for office.
So he is.
He's the most intriguing,
interesting and intriguing to me along
with trump and trump.
Although he says a lot of really stupid
things and he's ridiculous and he's his
ego's out of control.
And the shit that he says about Mexicans
is deplorable.
He's so wealthy that he can do whatever
the fuck he wants and he's using all of
his own money to fund this campaign and
he won't be a puppet the same way that
Ted Cruz or Marco Rubio or any of these
other guys on the right.
Will those guys scare the fuck out of me
that Ted Cruz guy scares the fuck out of
him.
He's really framing.
He's so dumb,
but he's not dumb.
That's what scary.
He's,
uh,
he's,
he's very smart as far as education.
But the shit that he says and Oh my God,
I think the Hillary thing though,
there's also a majority of people who
from that party who will vote to keep
things going on the Obama track.
Yeah.
I think that there's enough of that that
just kind of Grin and bear voting for
Hillary,
Hillary Clinton versus Putin.
I mean,
who knows what the fuck happens if Putin
decides to ramp it up because hillary
becomes president.
That's pretty tough though.
She,
she had that job.
you know,
Faccia wasn't a pushover,
right?
She wasn't,
she wasn't nasty,
real queen,
whatever the fuck she was.
I don't know man,
that little promise.
She just so non compelling to me.
There's nothing she says.
It's interesting.
A great photo that I put up on instagram
that somebody made of the difference
between Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton in regard to their response.
Like what is the olive garden like?
How do,
how do you feel about the olive garden?
It's funny,
I'll show Jamie pull it up because it's
so hilarious.
But it is how I feel about Hillary
Clinton.
Like I feel like she's.
Yeah,
I know,
but you know what?
It's politics,
but she's also boring.
Yeah.
And I think that is something you kind
of appreciate when they're in office.
Really?
Yes.
Obama's kind of boring and wonkish any,
but it just kinda no drama.
No big.
I mean this is kind of,
I'm talking against her at the same
time,
but with Obama there was no scandal.
There was no do surgery,
there was no things taking us off track
day just kind of went to work
methodically.
It wasn't flashy,
wasn't exciting,
but it's improved.
Here it is all garden and authentic
Italian restaurant for the whole family
says Hillary Bernie.
Only when I'm high,
I don't make sense.
It totally.
Yeah.
There's a whole group.
I just think that um,
this is just,
there's no one that really grabs me.
Like Al Know Al Gore when he was running
opposite of Bush was compelling.
I'm like,
here's a guy who cares a lot about the
environment.
You know,
people is,
oh,
he's bullshit.
That movie an inconvenient truth is
filled with books and bullshit and lies
and propaganda.
Not One question about climate change in
the Republican debates.
Yeah.
They want to keep the that on the DL.
Not One pill.
Addictions,
like we're saying,
pharmaceutical addictions,
cigarettes.
I mean if there was a drug that just got
released that's killing as many people,
cigarettes,
that would be the number one hot topic
for debate.
If there was a,
a disease like the Zika virus,
it was killing a half million people.
It would be the number one hot,
huge topic of debate.
Half a million people a year in this
country alone.
But cigarettes skirt right under the
radar.
Yeah.
It's because the amount of money they
contribute.
Yeah.
Same thing with pharmaceutical drugs.
The heroin problem in New Hampshire.
Right?
Well,
why do you think that drumming up such
fear about all the terrorism is so good
because these guys want to come.
It's the same thing with the industrial
complex.
They want to just.
Those guys spend a lot of money on those
politicians,
but you also know the whole reality of
the New Hampshire heroin problem was
entirely spawned entirely spawned by
oxicon.
Right?
It was people that got oxycontin's.
They got them easy and cheaply,
and then they cramp down on it when they
found that all these people are
addicted,
so what did they do?
Did they fix it?
Then they cure their addiction.
No.
They made these poor fucking people try
to figure out some other way to get
their fix and the way to do that was
heroin a cheaper way to get it?
To get it?
The only way to get it because he
couldn't get the pills anymore,
so they started shooting up.
That's where it came from.
Exactly.
It was all spawned out of the
prescription drug problem that we have
in this country.
Apparently that movie that those guys
came in here,
this prescription thugs.
Apparently it's very good and there's
some insane fucking stats,
statistics about it and I'll try to get
those guys to come back in and talk
about it after I'm there.
They're doing their their press cycle
right now and after I watch it,
but a the same guys who did bigger,
stronger,
faster,
which was supposedly on steroids.
Did this expose a on prescription drugs?
Yeah,
Chris Brown and mark his brother,
but it's terrifying.
Terrifying,
terrifying.
Oh.
What's so scary as a parent is that you
could basically raise this beautiful
person their whole life and get to the
whatever age.
Let's put them as you know,
17 to 25 when they're out on their own
doing their thing.
One bad summer,
one horrible week,
one intense weekend,
and you can lose them.
Well,
how about this?
Someone could fucking give them
something and they can die from it.
Someone can lie to them.
Someone could bill cosby them,
give them some shit that they think is
going to whack them out so they can have
sex with your daughter.
Crazy die of an overdose.
That happens.
It's insane.
You can't even.
You can't even have your kids go to a
party.
You can eat,
drink.
You can't have a sour patch kid.
Especially.
Can't do any.
I know women have to be very careful
about what they drink.
You know,
I.
I know,
I know people who've been drugged.
I met people who have been drugged this.
It's very common.
Yeah.
Guys dropped completely.
Terrifying Shit,
man.
Terrifying.
This is bill cosby thing is,
you know,
I think it's awful.
It's horrific,
but it at least it's opening up this
discussion that I think we need to have
in this country about men who are
willing to drug women and have sex than
weather out.
That is a creepy,
sociopathic,
psychopathic type of person.
So creepy.
It's scary.
It's it really empowerful.
People like him wasn't the other one
from the singing show.
He was.
He was given a.
allegedly wasn't cee lo green busted for
given girls ecstasy just without them
knowing.
Yeah.
Allegedly,
allegedly,
allegedly who the guy who looks like a
peanut m and m was trying to get.
Get some boats.
We had some pressure.
I couldn't do it any other way.
I met him once they get on a plane,
I was like,
oh Jesus Christ.
For sure.
Stop eating dude.
Settle down gluten grain and everything.
Take bowls stomach.
He had that one song that fuck you song.
Great Song.
It was a good song.
And that launched the whole thing is
that uh,
since those allegations,
I think he's kind of disappeared,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know what the deal is.
I mean he might be in the middle of a
trial or something.
I mean,
just to knock them out.
We'll access.
He doesn't knock them out,
but I think it makes them much more
willing to have sex.
But back to the cosby thing,
like what you're saying,
like that issue of guys that are just
willing to knock women out.
Oh,
why do you feel good about yourself the
next.
As soon as it's over,
it's not about that.
It's about getting back at women,
I think.
Is it?
Yeah.
I think there's women out there that
hate men and there's men out there that
hate women.
I think at this point it's ridiculous to
pretend anything different and I think
there's a direct correlation between
people that have been rejected and
people that have associated women with
someone who's going to turn them down or
treat them like shit because they're not
physically attractive.
Right.
This fucking guy is built like a peanut
m and m's.
Right.
You know,
you know,
I was lucky enough where I never had
those interactions with girls coming up
with funny.
It was funny and pretty good looking.
Well,
you know,
but a meeting friends as an adult who
women just screwed them over in their
mind,
in their,
in their fable.
They come out with a whole different
view of womanhood.
Yeah.
I mean,
mine was really pleasant and I always
see women as the victim or I always see
women and the guys who had a really
shitty time and they got jumped on and
whatever.
There's a rage that these guys carry
around that it's really just kind of
like a stroke of luck that when I was
young I met them.
Nice ones.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
These guys are really like,
you know,
you see guys like and they kind of say
jokes about like knocking a girl out and
doing all those kinds of events.
It's not really.
They're not really kidding in a way.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's a darkness anytime you talk about
women,
right?
These guys,
well,
there's always going to be people that
got fucked over by somebody and if
you're involved in a horrific divorce,
and I have a friend who was involved in
a horrific divorce that took years and
I've talked about on this podcast ad
nauseum.
Unfortunately he's,
he's got to pay her for the rest of his
life because you were married for 12
years,
so he,
she's a grown woman.
If you have a fucking kid when the kids
18,
they're on their own.
Yeah,
but not.
Not a woman.
Like if you have a woman and you're
married to her for 12 years,
by the way,
they were divorced more than 12 years
ago,
so he has to pay her forever,
forever,
until she died.
So she fucking die.
So if she gets into some life extension
shit,
some new science comes out.
He and he lives for 500 years and she
lives for 500 years.
He's going to have to pay her for some
shit that he doesn't even remember
anymore.
Oh my God.
And I'm not talking about a small amount
of money either.
He's wealthy,
so he's paying her hundreds of thousands
of dollars a year.
More than a half a million.
I think.
So it's his rage like,
oh,
that's crazy.
If you get them started up,
he just needed.
He literally needs a drink really start
bubbling in his mind because the whole
thing was a fuck.
California.
Yeah.
There's bad divorce laws and there's
really bad horrible ones and if you get
the wrong lawyer and she gets the right
one.
Oh God.
It's just insane that you don't have to
move on with your life like as a woman,
but a woman is married to a guy and
we're not talking about someone with
children and she doesn't even have any
children.
Right?
Like there's,
this is indefensible because people said
no children.
I've heard people say,
yeah,
but you know,
she's got to raise the kids.
What kids know kids and when you tell
them that they go,
wait,
what?
Actually she doesn't even have any kids
and he has to pay her for ever forever
millions and millions and millions of
dollars by the time she's dead for
nothing,
for nothing.
Forgot.
They had a relationship relationship
with time together and he didn't want to
be with her anymore,
so he has to pay her forever.
Oh,
it's the most horrific form of
prostitution known to man.
Oh my God.
It's crazy.
We're not talking about child support.
That's insane.
Now we're not talking even about a woman
who like put the guy through school
while he was working on his engineering
degree or something like that.
And then he went on to become successful
and tried to abandon her and she's like,
Hey,
I put you through school.
I'm responsible for part of your
success.
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah.
Nope.
Never worked.
Never.
Never worked while she was with him.
Never worked.
Yeah,
don't worry,
baby.
I'll take care of you.
You don't have to work.
How does the law support that?
Because they're cunts.
Cunt festival up there.
Oh,
whoever creates it.
Whoever forces it.
Whoever looks at that on paper and says,
that's good.
That's how it's written.
You should.
A media should come from God's hand and
fucking blow your brains out.
It's insane.
That is crazy town.
It's so gross.
That is scary.
It's scary.
It's really scary.
What if he just got a job as a busboy?
Well,
he's response and went to like a studio
apartment and didn't make that much
money anymore.
Well,
I've got another one,
Dave.
Cool.
Yay.
No,
God damn it from a news.
Newsradio.
Jesus Christ.
Dave,
want to draw a blank on date because,
uh,
this one hurts my brain so much.
I draw blanks.
Now.
Dave Foley got divorced and his wife
wanted money.
That is like the way they establish how
much money he was going to pair was
depending upon how much money he was
making at the time.
So he was on news radio when they got
divorced,
so that was the highlight of his entire
life as far as how much money he's ever
going to make in a month.
Right.
So they based it on a percentage of
that,
like 50 percent of that,
which he will never.
I mean right now he's never made.
I mean,
I don't know if he will.
Maybe he will.
He's a very talented guy.
He might have a hit next week,
but as far as right now,
it's never made that kind of money ever
again in his life.
So He owes hundreds of thousands of
dollars.
Can't go to Canada.
If he goes to Canada,
they'll arrest him and the DA.
The judge literally said to him,
your ability to pay has no relation to
your obligation to pay.
So you have an obligation to obey.
I do not care if you're able to able to,
you have an obligation to make more
money.
Oh my God.
But in the end,
and that's the judge's words to his face
and it's not like,
you know,
even $100,000
working at straight gig.
That's like winning the lottery.
Yeah.
They based it on his winning ticket.
He won the lottery based network show.
Yeah,
he won.
He got the cushiest spot ever,
which is a network Sitcom in the
nineties,
right back when they were real.
It's not a,
you cannot,
they don't even exist anymore.
That.
How many sitcoms are there now?
They're 10 million actors in Hollywood
trying to get on 10 sit.
Right?
Oh.
And he's 50 something so it's not going
to happen.
I mean,
they don't want the 57 guy.
They want the guy that he was in the
nineties,
they want the 30 year old guy.
Oh my God.
What a nightmare.
Fucking Christ.
And He's another one.
You're around him when he talks about it
and you just need a drink.
I can drink.
You start small.
It's so sad.
Ice Cubes,
dance classes and whiskey starts pouring
and you're like,
fuck.
And he is the nicest guy.
Yeah,
he is one of the handful of nicest
people I've ever met in my life and he
talks about his ex wife goes,
she's a contact.
She is and she will not negotiate.
She will not lessen his money.
She will not.
She doesn't give a fuck.
She wants to torture him.
She's as crazy as that crazy person.
Oh,
it's so gross.
But that's these crazy laws.
And when people say,
well,
why do you think why?
Like even my own wife,
like I say,
the Saint Mary's is retarded.
It's ridiculous.
I am happy.
I'm happily married.
I love her.
She's great.
I love having a family.
It is fucking dumb.
Well,
you shouldn't say that.
That's fucking dumb.
I shouldn't say it.
If you were making all the money you'd
say to,
it's great to see.
He took.
It's a legal contract with the state
that involves two people getting along.
That's insane.
It's one of the most transient things
that we can do is try to establish
sexual relationships with each other.
Often those fucking things.
Last,
none of them lasts forever.
Well,
it's really,
it's really a business.
You're really creating a business and it
becomes a big business as you go further
on and bring on other employees and
children in that kind of thing,
and this is why you're not allowed to
have sex with your coworkers because
that makes things very complicated,
right?
Yeah.
If you.
If you have a job and you have a
secretary and you start banging your
secretary and she's a part of this
business that you've created with your
wife,
you got real issues,
you're experiencing pleasure from
someone else and that's like,
you know,
like if you are working on a set,
you can't plug something in because it
was a union electrician,
right?
It's his job,
You need that union electrician.
Otherwise that guy wouldn't really be
able to justify his position.
Well,
your,
your wife is your Dick Technician and if
your secondary,
not only does she handle your paperwork
but also handles your Dick.
Well,
we've got a problem here because we have
one too many employees.
It's very complicated.
Well,
this try and keep that on the rails.
Yeah.
The secretary is really good at plugging
things in and um,
I just feel like I don't need someone
else.
So it's all a bitch.
The kids are 18 fuck off.
Was going to be a big lawsuit.
Well yeah.
Madeline Albright on speed dial eight.
Or is it where you got divorced?
I think where you got married as big,
it's the bigger part is a big one.
If you get married in California,
that's like one of the worst places.
One of my.
Yeah,
it's one of the worst places.
One of my favorite stories was this New
York.
I'm really wealthy.
Fucking millionaire,
multimillionaire business guy marries
this young lady.
He's in his sixties.
She's in her 30 [inaudible].
She's hot as fuck.
He marries her and then when he marries
her,
he immediately files for divorce in the
Dominican Republic,
believe is Dominican Republic.
Write this story up because it was real
recent.
She had no idea they were married the
entire time.
She thought they were married,
but he had filed for divorce and had
attorneys represent her and him in
absentia.
He paid for both lawyers on the case and
got divorced.
So he didn't have any country in another
country,
so he's saying we're not married.
Bitch got divorced weeks afterwards.
Here's my paperwork.
It's binding in the Dominican Republic.
This is a legal document.
Really?
Where'd they get married?
In the station?
Yeah,
I think so.
In the states.
She's.
Yeah.
Mick Jagger.
Try to do the same thing with Jerry
Hall.
Oh really?
He's like,
bitch,
we didn't even get married.
America.
We got married on like a fucking coconut
island somewhere.
So he was saying that that didn't count
either.
Oh my guy.
Yeah.
Here's the guy.
Husbands secretly divorced wife after
wedding to protect his assets and look
at him and look at her.
She's hot and young.
Of course they were married for 20
years.
Raising a son and living the good life
in between homes in New York and France.
I'm like,
it was all perfect except one thing.
He had secretly divorced her just months
after their wedding in an apparent
attempt to shield his assets.
He's 90.
Yeah.
And now she's 59.
She's suing her in a 90 year old husband
to nullify the divorce that she never
knew about.
And keep him from selling an apartment
that they shared that they met in 1994.
So they met when he was 70.
He knew what was going on.
Yeah,
he was 70 and probably shouldn't no to
the prenup.
And she was more than 30 years.
Uh,
his senior.
Huh?
She was like somewhere around 30
something years old as fuck.
Marrying a 70 year old guy.
She says it's a fraud.
She tells the post,
well,
well it's the fraud.
Now what?
What did you do to get that apart?
Where's,
where's your money coming from,
lady?
How's that work?
But it's not good enough.
See,
we've established that when someone
marries someone,
they won the lottery.
When you marry some old rich dude like
that guy,
you've won the lottery and then you
deserve to get paid from winning that
lottery.
But the reality is what?
What,
what exactly was going on in that
relationship?
They were together and he made all the
money and she wants some of that money
that he made while she was living in the
same place as him.
And that's really what it is.
If you're an athlete,
a professional athlete,
how do you possibly meet someone and
think,
this is gonna,
go against you.
Well,
sometimes it works.
Sometimes you can meet the right people,
man.
It's just.
It's really who are you?
Who are they?
It's so hard to generalize and some
relationships work great and some
marriages worth grade some marriages
where both people make a similar amount
of money and then no one is really in it
for the money and they had just their.
They have a modest living and they enjoy
themselves and they just love being
together and they liked the fact that
they were a ring and hey,
that's my wife.
That's my husband.
We're happy.
We love it.
This is great.
That's nothing wrong with that.
The real problem is when you break up
like my buddy who went through this
horrific,
horrific divorce,
he married a new woman after that and
she didn't want to sign a prenup and he
was going fucking crazy.
You know,
and,
and everyone was screaming at him,
all of his friends do not do this.
You have to find it.
She's like,
you're saying that it's not going to
work.
He's like,
no,
because if it doesn't work then the
prenup doesn't mean anything and he has
a history of always saying,
if it doesn't work,
the Prenup is valuable.
It comes in handy,
but if it does,
like what I'm saying is if this marriage
works,
if you do your part,
I do my part.
We'll work it out.
We make it beautiful.
We stayed together forever.
The prenup doesn't mean shit because
every time you together forever,
right?
So if the marriage is going to work,
the problem,
it only,
it only means something if it doesn't
work out.
If you're looking at it as an
investment.
So what she is hoping for or what she's
saying essentially is if it doesn't work
out,
I want you to get fucked over and you're
protecting yourself.
You're protecting yourself from the
legal system that's set up the fuck you.
If you and I don't want to be together
anymore,
you have to get punished.
You must be punished financially and he
has a whole story that he could hold up
in front of her.
Like,
you know,
I am suffering.
Any works like,
so what do you do?
Hours?
He's got a prenup.
He does know he got through it.
Yeah,
he was good.
He wouldn't do it.
He could you the beating that he took,
but he lost a house.
He lost.
I mean it's.
The whole story is comical.
The ex wife lives in with a guy now,
but she's not allowed to.
So when they go to inspect the house,
the guy literally puts all this stuff in
a u haul drives around the corner,
which did inspect her leave and drives
back.
It's a game.
Can you get a private investigators?
Doesn't matter.
You have to prove it.
The private investigator.
What?
What evidence did he discovers?
Like you can't.
There's only so much privacy.
You can violate someone's home.
It's not his home.
His own home where he could put in his
own home and catch his wife bag and some
fucking personal trainer.
This is not that.
This is her house now,
by the way,
multimillion dollar house in the
palisades really overlooking the ocean.
All hers.
Oh God.
Ow.
It hurts.
When you find out what happened to you
in a divorce.
It's horrific,
but what happens if he seriously gets a
job working at a diner and it's like no
one knows.
No one will hire me.
He would have to go back to court and
we'd would have to figure out a way to
get a judge to agree to lower the terms.
But the problem is he's responsible for
maintaining her lifestyle.
So if he takes that job,
he could actually be put in prison.
Yes,
because he's not making enough.
Exactly.
Well,
he would have to get a judge that agrees
to maintain,
to lower the lifestyle that he has been,
that he's obligated to maintain.
He's obligated to maintain a certain
lifestyle for her.
Oh my God.
It's insane.
We're not talking about substantially.
We're not talking about subsistence.
We're not talking about like you have to
extrapolate to give her $50,000
a year and that's enough for her to
survive on.
And she wasn't that way.
She doesn't have to get a job or maybe
you have to give her a $100,000
for two years until she can figure out
how to get a job like that.
She's a human being.
She's a person.
She's intelligent,
she's articulate,
she has an education.
She's not a handicap person.
She's not diseased like she's not broken
like where she can't work.
She doesn't have feet.
She's like a regular person,
a regular person.
It's fucking madness.
Wow.
I made it is mostly madness.
It's really the worst case scenario.
The thing is in,
unless you're with these people,
you don't know these stories unless you
know someone that's gone through this,
you don't know these stories,
and then when you hear these men's
rights groups and then you hear
feminists mock men's rights groups like
this is.
This is the reason why a lot of people
won't take feminism seriously and this
because a lot of them mock these men's
rights groups and this is also the
reason why a lot of these men's rights
groups have a valid point because
there's a lot of men's rights points
that are stupid as far.
What do you care if these feminists
don't like you?
What do you care?
They bitch about the way you act or
dress unless you work with them.
What do you care?
Right?
You know,
if you're.
If you're trapped in some office with
some man hating woman and she has a
position above you and she's making your
life hell well,
that's no different than being trapped
in an office with some sexist pig.
Man.
If you're a woman,
it's.
It's terrible.
If someone is gender specifically biased
in any way,
shape or sure,
but in,
unless you see the devastation that it
can,
it someone's life like day Foley's life.
From the time that I met him,
to the time that he got divorced when he
was on Newsradio,
his life has been overwhelmingly
influenced by this woman that he used to
be married to,
that he doesn't even know anymore.
Yeah.
I mean,
he doesn't see her anymore.
He hasn't.
He hasn't had sex with her in decades,
but they're still inexorably connected
financially and it has ruined his life.
These are two pages to people I know who
have to pay the women that they used to
sleep with more than 20 years ago.
He has to.
They have to pay them forever.
Oh my God.
And that's just one story.
And the,
the problem is the court system,
and this is one of the things that I was
going over with Phil Hartman before his
wife murdered him.
I was telling him,
you know,
I'm,
I,
I grew up in a really fucked up house.
Like when I was little,
my parents split up when I was young
there was violence and there was just
like,
and my mom,
when my dad hit my mom,
my mom got her shit and got the fuck
out.
I saw it.
I saw him hit her eye and then we moved
to my grandpa's,
my grandfather's house.
Like immediately afterwards we were out
and apparently he had done it before and
you know,
he terrorized her and she was just like,
fuck this.
We're gone.
So my,
in my mind when Shit goes bad,
you've got to fucking pull strings,
get you just get out,
just get out.
So I was telling Phil,
I go,
dude,
get out of there man.
Just get out.
It was like.
He was like,
it's not that simple.
He's like,
you don't give half.
I was a kid her half.
He's like,
it's not half.
He goes,
it's two thirds because the fucking
lawyers get a third.
He likes it's a business.
He's like,
you have to understand there's a
business involved in law.
Who's a business involved in divorce?
First of all,
he had to pay for her lawyer.
He's like,
I have to pay for her lawyer.
I have to pay for my lawyer.
And there's two lawyers.
They're to battle it out and they're
gonna.
Drag it out as long as possible to make
the most money.
Just ruin your life.
Oh well they get a percentage and they
get legal to get paid by the hour.
So the whole thing is just brutality.
Keep it going.
And if you have somebody who's a little
off,
you can just keep fueling the fire.
Just keep it going.
Well,
you know Carla blow.
Yeah.
Okay.
How about this one?
Carlo,
who used to be in the outlaws of comedy
with Sam Kinison,
Sam Kinison Fuck Carla Bose wife and got
her pregnant.
Was Bo,
was raising Sam kinisons child thinking
it was his own.
He got into DNA test after Sam Kennison
died,
found out it wasn't his child,
tried to get out of paying child
support.
And they said,
no,
you have to pay child support forever.
So Carl Lebow owes hundreds of thousands
of dollars for Sam's baby.
He,
he first,
Sam's baby,
he's fucked.
He,
um,
his credit is ruined.
He doesn't have a car.
I mean,
he's,
he's devastated by this.
Just a working comic to comic.
Yeah,
I mean not,
not.
I mean a road comic road guy who does it
does well.
It does headlines,
but he can't see.
It's not like A.
Yeah.
But.
So he tried to fight it and lost.
And so now because he lost,
he has to pay,
but he's responsible for another man's
child because his wife had an affair and
it doesn't matter.
Why does that not matter?
Because we are living in a system that
looked limit or fucked over in this
country.
Let's just,
let's just make this as a caveat.
Women get fucked over in this country
all the time.
I mean there.
Absolutely.
Besides what we're talking about with
men that are willing to drop pills and
girls drinks,
there's women that work in offices with
pieces of shit for bosses and they
sexually harassed them and fuck with
them and make their life was horrible
and create this boy's club environment
that makes it terrible for them to work
in.
There's absolutely.
That is absolutely key,
but when it comes to divorce and when it
comes to a man who makes money and the,
the preying upon that,
man that happens.
It's fucking Hoe.
It's horrific.
That should be a documentary.
It's so much a follow those stories
around like being really because people
don't know those stories.
Yeah.
An inconvenient truth.
Yes.
Another one rather inconvenient truth.
So it's,
you know,
it's bad man.
There's a lot of California,
California,
California has that law and in some ways
I kind of understand because like,
look,
um,
I have a stepdaughter and she's,
as far as I feel she's my daughter.
I mean,
I treat her like she's my daughter and
if I found out that one of my actual
daughters was actually not my biological
daughter,
I wouldn't love them any less.
No.
I wouldn't want my wife to get giant
chunks of money because of it,
but if it was about supporting the kid,
I would never change that.
I've never changed that because that's.
But his case is more than that.
It's to support her also.
Well,
that's a fucked up situation,
man.
It's God Damn Sam Kennison like,
why doesn't the Sam kinison estate,
I mean,
how much money are they making?
Right?
How come they're not?
Why don't they pay it?
Right.
That's his kid.
You're talking about a wealthy man who
died,
who was one of the greatest comics who
ever lived.
I could only assume,
like I read something the other day that
said that Liverpool just Liverpool gets
100 million dollars a year from the
Beatles.
I don't know how the fuck that works,
but just the tax is involved.
You know,
the amount of money that they generate
from their portfolio,
the taxes from all the sales.
Who knows?
Right.
You're not making my innocent anymore
though.
Yeah,
Kenny.
But kennison had generated a few
million.
Yeah,
but that's gone.
Right?
I mean there's a whole generation that
doesn't even know Sam anymore.
Unfortunately.
God isn't crazy as a kid that does a
great impression of Kennison and it went
up and crack gas.
Yeah,
I think so.
Knowing the factory.
No idea.
Who's talking about.
Well,
that's the thing.
We were talking about this Oj case,
like you and I,
we were around when the Oj trial was
going on,
but a lot of kids today,
they don't even fucking have any idea
what this about.
No idea.
We're old dude.
How old are you now?
How old are you?
Thirty nine.
I'm 48.
So how old are you for real seven.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It gets you mad.
It's all of a sudden you're like,
Holy Shit,
we've lived.
We've,
we've been around,
we've seen some shit.
But then you see people that are older.
I always gravitate towards those people.
I'm like,
he's still rocking it.
He's still going.
Some people are,
but less,
less white because they die.
But yeah.
Well,
as you know,
a,
Jamie and I were just talking about
this,
me and Brian Cowen,
we're uh,
we're doing this podcast the other day,
about a week there was a,
we do this podcast called the fight
companion and it's a,
uh,
we watched the UFC fights and we talk
about fighting.
We'd get drunk and get retarded in one
of the,
the little exchanges that we have.
We were,
Brian was throwing kicks and I was
teaching them how to throw kicks.
Right.
And one of the things that people were
saying like,
these guys are 50,
how are they even doing that?
Right.
Jesus Christ,
like they think we're dead.
But then I'm like,
well,
how many people do I know that are 50
that are,
that are taking care of themselves?
Yeah.
It gets a number.
I know,
you know,
I'm 40 years old when I'm 90.
I'm probably not gonna be able to do
anything.
That's just a fact.
So I'm halfway to not being mobile.
Do any of that.
Yeah man.
I mean,
what at what level?
At what age do you get where your body
just doesn't work right anymore?
All right,
well that's the thing,
if you're active,
you gotta stay active,
you got to stay.
I mean no joke and when going to that
yoga class where it's,
you know,
the after drop off and there's some
older people to see like a 70 year old
woman and they're like standing on her
head and doing a backward backbend
because she kept doing that.
That's why she's able to do that now.
That's one of the things is the place
that I go to a some really good
instructors and one of the things that
this lady was talking about was she's in
her,
I want to say she's in her sixties and
she was saying that if you just maintain
your practice and keep doing it,
you can be healthy and mobile deepen
your nineties.
A lot of it is just people neglecting
their body.
Atrophy were just.
Yeah,
you see people that can't even touch
their toes anymore.
It's weird.
I got to go to the gym and as you get
older,
one really important thing is lifting
weights.
It's very important for older people
because you need to maintain muscle mass
just to avoid being injured and bone
density don't they say like you have to
really Max out as much as you can up
until up to 50.
Like it's because that's when you really
start to fall off muscle wise.
Um,
I dunno,
I haven't heard that.
No,
you're,
you're slowly falling off from the time
you're like 30 is the whole key is just
maintaining a level of activity.
You have to maintain a level of activity
but also maintain a level of
maintenance.
And that's where I really love yoga
because yoga is taken care of.
A lot of,
like weird back pains that I used to
have and things and weird shit.
It's weird isn't all of a sudden all
this goes away.
All that tensions.
Yeah.
I haven't gone to amazing.
It is amazing.
It's,
there's a reason why those skinny
motherfuckers in India been doing it for
a thousand years.
You're right.
It's really good for you.
I know it's.
Do you do it high?
Ever do it,
Huh?
No,
no,
no.
Really?
Yeah.
Where do you get high?
How often you get high?
Not that often anymore.
What does that mean?
Once a month.
Once a year.
Once every couple of months.
Yeah.
You should do it.
I want to do it all the time.
If you don't have anything to do during
the day that happened,
we'll just take a day.
Take a day where you tell your agent or
whoever the fuck it is.
It bothers you.
Say,
listen off the fucking grid today.
Then I'm also telling my wife,
I'm not picking the kids up.
I'm not doing this.
No time do you have to pick your kids up
for,
for you're good.
Take a 9:00
AM class.
You'll be fine.
Yeah.
Just get barbecued.
Drop the kids off,
drop the kids off,
take four strong hits and go to yoga
class.
Really will feel your body in a way
where you never felt it before.
You'll feel like your vertebrae
stretching and the tissue in your neck
loosening and it's like,
I'm doing that tomorrow.
Well,
that's one of the secrets of the
[inaudible] and the Yogis of India is
they would.
They would smoke all these chillums,
they would smoke,
hash the hash heads,
and they would go and do their practice.
That's really a big part of it.
Yeah.
I'm going to try it.
I wanted it so bad.
I can completely.
Yeah,
could fill it for the first time in my
life,
I've always been active always for the
first time in my life I have this issue
where I've got a muscle under here under
the first rib.
It's tight and it's affecting back here
down to my arm and it's affecting how
it's cutting off whatever nerves are
running down here.
Oh,
it's like it's cutting.
It's raising the.
This rib,
it's actually.
It's a stall.
Tight muscles tightened.
The rib is pulled up and it's pinching
on the stuff that's coming down.
Do you feel any numbness?
Sometimes.
Okay,
and so going to this great guy,
he's great.
He works with the clippers and stuff and
he's knows exactly where it is and he's.
And it's helping,
but he's like,
what do not sleep on?
Your stomach just goes in and loosens it
up and it's basically just kind of
releasing the tension of tissue and it's
working and feel it,
you know,
it's only a couple of times.
And uh,
there's two parts of this.
One is I can't sleep.
I sleep on my stomach with my head to
the side.
I used to do that.
I fucked my neck up doing that.
That's exactly what happened.
And it's really,
that's the cause,
the cause of it and I,
but my sleep,
I'm used to doing that my whole life.
Now I'm laying on my back.
It's so hard to sleep.
I lay on my side.
You do?
Yeah.
I lay on my side.
I put a pillow in between my legs.
This is,
I literally,
when I was driving here,
it's like Joe will know I had the same
exact issue by the denial.
Yeah.
Before I hurt my neck,
hurt my neck from Jujitsu.
But before I did that,
I started developing problems in my neck
from laying down.
That's it.
I had no idea.
It was just from laying down on your.
Especially if you laid down flat within,
turn your head in the same way,
right?
Always turn your head to the right.
Always.
You're fucked.
If you ever heard of those cab drivers
develop.
Swollen discs are bulging discs because
they sit with a wallet in their pocket.
Right?
Because just that lifting of your butt
cheek,
that an inch on
one side fucks your backup repeatedly.
Yeah,
because that's what you're doing when
you're sleeping.
Yeah,
it's really bad for you.
Tissue is really pliable.
It is like everything's out of whack.
So you have to kind of like reset it.
They'll reset me and then it's like,
all right,
just don't lift your arm and try and be
cool and just kind of let it learn that
it's got.
It's back in its place.
You see that little ball?
That little blue ball right here.
Hold on a little balloon behind the
creepy guy.
Oh,
this heavy.
what's this?
That is a,
that's called a mobilitywod supernova.
That's a smaller one.
I actually prefer there's a larger one
that we have around here somewhere.
Um,
I,
I give them to people because I want
people to use these things.
People have sore backs.
Will you do is you put it on the ground
or on a wall and you back up against it
and like put your weight on it and you
rub it up and down,
like you roll the ball and it breaks up
all the scar tissue and loosens up all
the tendons and all the Fascia.
It's painful,
but if you get them,
if you can bite your teeth and get
through it,
it'll make a significant difference in
loosening up your muscles.
It's such a strange idea.
Like I've never had any issue.
I've worked out.
I was an athlete my whole life and never
literally I've ever been like,
oh,
that hurt for the first time and I had
no idea the concept that all the tissue
and tendons are just tightening and I'm
just ending up like,
like a,
like a hunchback will.
That's all one of the things that pot
will help because we feel all those
things.
You feel tense like marijuana.
It's almost like it.
Whatever sensitivity you have about your
body awareness ramps it up to 10
minutes.
Why sex feels so good when you.
When you smoke,
because it just ramps up all the
feeling.
It's just.
It changes the way you interface with
the nerve endings.
I'm scared now to lift for the first
time.
I'm not lifting railing for like since
like October.
Ooh,
that's not good because that'll fuck it
up even more because you're right.
Yeah.
You lose strength in your back.
You need to go to a personal trainer
that understands how to strengthen that
area to keep this whole thing from
happening.
I mean,
he works with the clippers.
He's and he's running two times and it's
like,
all right,
we're onto it sounds.
You have a good massage therapist guy,
right?
That's what he does.
He's massage.
She said he's like a chiropractor.
See,
I think I am practice mostly bullshit.
I don't know if he's physical therapist
or chiropractor.
I don't know what it is.
I think chiropractors are mostly
bullshit.
Nonsense.
Yeah.
I think they're mostly bullshit,
but one of the things that they do do is
all the other stuff outside of cracking,
like cold lasers work and massage work.
There's a lot of other different
effective methods of alleviating
pressure,
intention that work,
but all that back cracking stuff.
If you talk to like most people that,
uh,
that study it and then try to figure out
what exactly they're doing like this.
They're not doing anything.
They're popping things in place and if
you have something really fucked
up,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe if something's like really out of
whack and they can straighten it out,
most of the time that's not what's going
on.
Most of the time you're just getting
this sort of placebo effect where
they're pushing on your back and making
a noise.
Pop.
We got it.
We got it right.
You're good at Tom.
You're like,
I'm good.
I'm feeling right now.
This guy.
I mean,
I was really a mess.
Yeah.
I mean I literally couldn't go like this
without this.
Just going numb.
And uh,
he got,
I mean he was just like,
no,
it's right in here.
But at the tent and then cool for,
you know,
a week and then I'm sleeping.
I'm literally going to do it every week.
Yeah.
I got to loosen it up.
I mean,
it sounds a bit of a real.
Have you ever gotten your ad?
Rolfing done.
Rolfing thing is like a very painful
method of deep tissue massage where
they're,
they're stretching out your fascia and
facing up all these binding to negative
scar tissue,
all that stuff.
And uh,
that,
that can be super effective with all the
scar tissue just from whatever abuse you
didn't.
Life muscle polls that funny.
Oh really?
Healed tents up me.
Especially if you have a bad poll.
I've had a bunch of them or scar tissue
all over my back.
But I think yoga fixed a lot of it,
like really a lot.
I don't have any issues.
No,
but I do feel like as much as I love
yoga,
I do feel like you'd have to keep
lifting.
Yes.
And I haven't literally because this
started getting,
becoming a problem like around October,
November,
and I literally feel like soft.
Yeah.
The people that don't think that,
you know,
and I don't,
I just don't think they're right.
If you talk to people that are experts
in physical culture,
you know,
people that really understand like what,
what did you do,
what do you need to do to keep your body
at its most effective operating level?
And they say it's a bunch of different
stuff.
It's like you have to do cardio,
you have to lift weights,
you have to stretch.
Yoga is part of that.
Yeah,
it's part of it.
I was just,
I was just in Hawaii doing a Gig and uh,
I at the pool and just like,
you know,
they have no kids pool,
like the serenity pool kind of thing.
So there and so it's all guys that are
like,
you know,
late thirties to mid sixties.
Every guy walking around there was guys
that were athletic,
you know,
you could tell.
And then there's guys that are a
complete mess.
And then there's a whole bunch of in the
middle.
The Dad Bod,
the dad bod a little pudgy and no
shoulders.
They all,
their shoulders have disappeared and you
can just see it just a bone bone went in
to.
I don't want to be ready to tear off.
It's really tried to pick up a suitcase
and it just from your basic life,
it can't end up like that.
No,
he can't.
Well,
some people,
they don't have a job like we have.
You know?
It's hard.
That's what I was talking about.
My friend who got divorced and fucked
over the guy works 12 hours a day.
Yeah.
When is he gonna?
Go to the gym.
He probably wouldn't be better off
though.
He gets a trainer and sometimes he goes
on his lunch break and stuff like that.
But the reality is he's working.
Yeah know.
I know you got to pay for his fucking
divorce,
but if you work out then it's kind of
like a.
your antidepressants.
She moved to Argentina should just
stockpile all of his cash,
get a fake fucking passport and just
you're on your own hook and just go.
They can't come get you.
Right.
If they don't know where he is,
they can't come get you.
I mean,
it's not like he's like,
I couldn't live with the paranoia.
That's true.
Especially Thinking,
Oh,
you're on the beach having a great time.
This is the life and the best.
They catch me and then it's not the life
in prison.
You a card.
Yeah,
everybody does.
You don't have one I don't like.
Yeah.
You want.
I've been so out of it.
Come on.
I know.
Just bring you to a place.
This is Tom Papa.
Hi Tom.
What's going on?
I need pot.
Okay.
I'm so out of it.
After I was every day for like a decade
and then just stopped.
Stopped.
It's hard when you have responsibilities
too and I wasn't as funny.
It was hurting my funny.
Was it really?
It was making me lethargic.
Oh,
he was making me.
Yeah,
it was making me a not as funny.
Well there's different kinds of pot to
and there's different reactions people
have to pot like some people.
Pot.
Pot makes me more actively but are not.
Yeah,
kind of me up.
Yeah.
Sativas,
especially right now,
it makes me like really ramped up like I
want to like go watch documentaries on
space,
write shit down.
Sometimes I'll smoke pot before I get
into a sensory deprivation tank and I
don't get,
I don't even get into the tank because
they have an idea and I have to write
and find myself in front of my computer
for hours.
That's sativa.
Does that?
Yeah.
And what's the other kind?
Indigo?
Indigo.
Indigo is like the couch.
We,
that's the physical.
The physical.
Yeah.
They're both,
but it's not.
It's more of a sedative.
Right,
right,
right.
More.
Let's look.
It's great for people in pain,
like glitter and a lot of pain.
Love Indycar,
like back pain,
like Oh,
relaxes them.
Is there anything to with Neil young was
talking about of chewing a coffee.
Beans makes you less paranoid.
You ever heard that one?
Caffeine definitely alleviates a lot of
the issues with thc.
You know,
if you're really too high,
the best thing you can do is drink
something with caffeine in it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's,
it's severely mitigates the effects of
thc.
Like if you,
if you go to like,
if you're a fucking way too hot,
just go to starbucks,
get vente Ralphie and just sit down,
relax.
It'll,
the caffeine will have a pretty big
impact.
But coffee beans,
um,
especially like raw coffee,
like coffee beans are very healthy for
you.
Yeah.
Like the actual been itself,
especially the outside of the coffee
bean,
like the green part of the coffee bean.
Very high in antioxidants.
I figured Neil young with new,
you know,
it's funny,
it's Kinda like,
it's Kinda like when you come back to a
sport,
like I was into cycling for awhile and
then like didn't do it and then came
back like eight years later and it's
like the whole sport had changed.
It just evolved so quickly and everybody
knew different carbon fiber and all this
different kind of.
That's the same thing with weed.
It's like I've been out of it.
So you come back,
you know,
this whole bunch of new things.
Now there's vape pens and sour gummies
tablets.
The kids try to get you to do dabs.
Wacky fucking kids.
You ever heard of the data?
Oh my God,
that's that.
It's uh,
it's,
it's really like you have all this
equipment and you're taking thc wax and
you're fucking going to stick and
fucking torch.
It's stupid.
I don't want to go old school.
I want to be fluffy.
Oh,
a big fluffy tree that I could see and
feel.
And how about joints?
Joint one.
I'd like to separate now it's like a
simple.
No,
no.
While we're here,
my tests little dry.
I'll just get you to carry him around in
a case like a fucking gentleman.
Then you got to show it in.
Are you doing a show tonight?
Be Out of my head.
I'll smoke this right before I go on
stage.
Do you really?
Hell yeah.
You're like a superman.
Oh,
I'm like a normal person.
No you're not.
No one's got the issues pal.
Yeah,
I got issues.
That's normal people.
Normal.
Someone that's mastering their issues.
This stuff's good for you.
I know it's good for you.
I'm going to crash my car if I a contact
high over here.
You want it just a little tiny hit?
No.
Alright.
What about your kids seeing you?
Smoking?
Didn't align.
What will they keep offline?
How old do they will?
They will though.
The youngest ones are seven and five.
They're online and they see me smoking.
We've got a real problem.
Two more years.
I'll be 24 months to come up with an
excuse.
They're going to go back.
Once they hit you too,
they're just going to go through the
files and I'll go.
That's what a dad does.
She is nice house we live in.
Yeah.
Daddy made this when he was high on
marijuana.
Marijuana is not bad for you.
I don't think it's bad for you.
Isn't bad.
It's bad for a kid though.
Yes.
If you don't want your kids do those
wine.
I drink wine in front of my children.
True.
I go to a restaurant and I have a couple
of glasses of wine in front of my
children and I don't have any problem
with it.
I've let them taste it.
Latino men,
they put it in their mouth like,
but wine is alcohol and you could drink
yourself to death.
You drink yourself to death off of wine.
People have done it before.
It smells so good.
Smells great over there.
But um,
there's nothing wrong with it man.
It's bullshit.
No,
I know.
I was just in Hawaii and it was just so
like,
Eh,
uh,
on.
Especially when you're in Hawaii,
just made for it.
Oh,
good Lord.
It's just so perfect.
Hawaii has a meth problem.
No.
Yeah.
A lot of poverty.
Well,
yeah.
I know there's parts of it that are just
a regular place.
Yup.
That's.
But that drives me crazy because I'm
like,
oh my God,
you live in arguably the greatest spot
on earth and somehow or another people
get hooked on meth there.
I know in her,
in a horrible strip mall and a sad it is
paradise there though.
Fuck you do it right and stay in the
right places.
Yeah.
The people are great to have a very
relaxed attitude about life.
It's magical.
Literally.
I mean you're just sitting there and in
the of the ocean,
the middle of the ocean and this little
island and all these other human beings,
some whatever their reason have joined
you on this island and there's this
giant whale with.
It's a baby whale,
just dancing right next.
You go under the water,
you hear them singing stars.
It's just.
Yeah,
we were there with wild masons and we
were on this tour where you,
uh,
you put on like,
um,
snorkel gear and then they find the pods
and you,
you,
they pull the boat within maybe 50 yards
of the pod and then you dive in the
water and swim over to the pods of
dolphins.
Now is amazing chefs.
But Hawaii has got a lot of fucking
shark attacks,
man.
They do.
I literally was like,
why aren't there more shark attacks?
And when I got home I looked it up.
There's a lot of sharks.
While we were there.
Somebody's got,
get hold.
No.
While we were there,
a woman from Germany got fucking marked
by a shark just swimming,
snorkeling.
Well,
we've been there three times.
When people got jacked by sharks,
a woman got killed and then another dude
got his leg essentially ripped off.
He was a local Hawaiian Kid who was
surfing and that was on the big island.
He Got Jack.
There was another time we were there.
I was watching the news and you know,
were out there in the water,
fucking calm as can be snorkeling and
having a good old time.
It's uh,
it's nerve wracking.
That's scary.
I'm glad I didn't know that when it was
out there trying to look for sea
turtles.
Yeah.
Two Thousand Fifteen was apparently the
biggest year ever recorded for shark
attacks.
What's the change?
Climate Change?
A really water's getting warmer and
they're just hanging the less food or
add.
They're mad.
They're mad at people for fucking up the
water.
He know the people are to blame.
I don't know what the reason is,
but I saw that recently,
like it was a headline of one of the
news stories over the last couple of
days.
The other thing that happens a lot in
Hawaii,
helicopter crashes.
They're not that infrequent.
Those tourist helicopters flipping
around.
Oh really?
It's a good list.
Really?
Yeah,
Dude.
I've been on those things out there.
You shouldn't tell you fuck with me
after I a lot.
Well,
you ruined my tesla experience.
Now I think someone's going to send me
into a record number of shark attacks in
2015 though.
Only six deaths.
Well,
imagine if the wolf man only killed six
people last year.
People like,
Oh,
it's fun to go outside with full moon.
Just get out in the woods.
It's not that man will then mostly eat
deer.
Yeah.
The wolf was the number of attacks.
So if there's six deaths,
how many attacks were there?
90 eight and 98 in one year.
Yep.
Ninety eight.
Twenty zero.
Say Twenty eight,
26.
March 26 more.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
In the previous year,
the number of shark attacks worldwide
with 98 incidents,
a whopping 26 more than the previous
year.
Wait,
and that's way more than a decade prior.
That's not Hawaii though.
That's international is an
international.
So it say that worldwide was not that
bad.
If you think about it worldwide.
So the wolf man,
if it was only like a few wolfman out
there worldwide,
even like kids,
a full moon,
but it's a nice full moon will go out
well here.
The twig snap will know the Werewolf is
not stealthy.
They howl,
they're assholes or they're scared of
silver.
We're fine.
I don't have to go in the ocean by the
way.
I can go to Hawaii and sit on a beach
happy.
I don't have to go.
Don't,
don't.
I'm not water stuff now.
I used to as a kid,
man.
Fishing in Hawaii is amazing.
Yeah.
Catching a fish and they bring it back
to the restaurant and they'll cook it
for you.
Most hotels,
like they'll have like a chef that have.
You asked them if you go on a fishing
trip,
if you organize it,
left a lot of them through the hotel.
You organize it out on a boat,
you know,
they,
they have like the little brochures
like,
Hey,
this guy,
I'll take you out for this kind of fish.
And so last time we went out we call a,
it's called the who called.
So delicious man.
And the chef prepared it three different
ways.
He grilled it,
he baked it,
and he served it as Sashimi.
Oh No,
four different ways because he made a
severe j to Oh my God.
Two hours old,
she's had severe ha like that,
a Costa Rica.
We came back and the guy just like,
they're like with all the,
you can just kinda lime jurors the hose
and he's just like chopping up avocado
or having so best thing you've ever
eaten so much.
Fish is one of those things where it
tastes so much better when it's fresh.
Completely the opposite with meat,
like meat actually tastes better when it
sits for a while.
That's why we buy dry aged meat.
Yeah.
Like sit in the steak house.
I'm just on a shelf for six months and
you're like 35 degrees.
They can do that.
So it develops this sort of crust of
bacteria on the outside.
Thirty five degrees if you've ever been
to.
I'm like a butcher shop and seeing dry
aged meat,
it will query you often meet for awhile.
You believe screen,
by the way,
queer you is not homophobic at all.
It was a perfect,
perfectly reasonable word to use in the
dictionary.
It's perfectly reasonable way to use it,
a loophole,
but um,
it looks rotten and black.
It looks like mold and they'll really
looks.
Yeah,
because the mold grows on the outside of
the meat and that's what's happening.
It's like bacteria is destroying the
outside of the meat and you cut that
away and what's underneath?
It's just tender and relaxed and
delicious.
It sounds like my neck after maybe you
need to eat mold on your neck.
Have you ever gone to Africa?
No,
I'm going in July,
Papa.
Boom,
buy a pop up.
I know a guy who knows a guy.
No,
it's a guy I worked for though,
who's a very.
And
uh,
I did a show for them and they are
singing my.
I just had to fly myself there with my
family and they're putting it.
There's these luxury resorts in these
national reserves
in Tanzania.
Oh whoa.
For 10 days.
So you're going to be surrounded by like
lions and shit?
Yeah.
Oh,
Tom.
Papa,
please don't die.
Yes.
A lot of guys with guns that will stand
around you.
Do you know about the woman who was the
editor?
A film editor,
a video editor from game of thrones?
No.
She got pulled out of her car by a lion
and killed.
She did.
Was she doing?
She was taking photographs and she
rolled down the window,
take a better picture,
and the lion grabbed her and pulled her
out of the car and killed her in front
of everybody.
Well,
nothing they could do about it.
That's not going to happen to us because
we're not going to have windows,
won't make eye contact.
They're open and no cameras.
And um,
it'd be armed to the tits.
I'll be honest with you.
I don't know.
I never had like a burning desire,
you know,
some places you want to get to,
like I want it to be in Italy or you
know,
I had no,
nothing in my soul was like Africa,
we must do Africa.
But South fraternity came up and it
seems pretty amazing and I feel like the
closer I get,
the more amped I'm getting about it.
But uh,
he was like,
I'm telling you,
it will change your life.
You'll just see this planet differently.
Once you go to Africa,
Africa,
you would like Africa.
I
thing I wouldn't like malaria.
So I'll watch DVD,
fuck you and fuck the Zika virus.
I could see you in Africa.
You're adventurous.
Yes,
I would go.
But um,
I would definitely be worried about
malaria.
Oh,
I'm worried about a lot of things for
sure.
But I am fat.
I'm a big fan of wildlife.
I'm fascinated by the wildlife there.
Although the reality of these parks is
almost artificial and a lot of ways how
they maintain everything and they,
they're doing it for,
for tourist money.
Like there's almost,
there's almost an artificial quality to
it because,
you know,
a lot of these places are fenced in and
so even though it's thousands and
thousands of acres like this,
it's some,
it's not quite fucked up.
It's not quite as zoo.
No,
no,
not at all.
And they're still migrating and there's
still all that stuff.
They're not feeding him.
No,
no,
no.
So it's still live and wild,
but it's like going into Yosemite.
He used to people,
man,
I hope so.
They do.
They get used to people.
And you're in these.
A lot of times you're in these open air
jeeps and we were talking about it on
the podcast.
I was saying like,
how?
How come these fucking animals don't
jump in there and almost as if on cue
after we said that a leopard jumped in a
jeep,
an open air jeep like a week later,
and I was like,
yeah,
why isn't that fucking happening every
day?
But I'm.
I wonder what if animals like lions just
start figuring that out the same way
keynote there's been,
there was an article recently,
they were talking about chimps that they
believe chimps have just started to
enter the stone age for the of
chimpanzee intelligence.
Like they literally might be evolving
before our eyes and they started to use
tools on a regular basis.
This observed champion.
Yeah,
they're coming.
Wow.
Might take a few million years,
but yeah,
if human beings have only been in this
form where they think for the last like
200 plus thousand years essentially
unrecognizable from Uri.
Like what the fuck?
What's the chimp going to be like in a
million years?
Awesome.
My Bay.
Right.
They might be like some crazy sasquatch
type thing,
some almost half human half monkey thing
running through the woods and we'll just
be like jelly fish with cars that drive
itself.
Prime rib eye balls in much.
Our cars never crashed,
so we make them out of paper.
That was logic is everyone's driving a
paper car.
No one's going to get hurt.
So knowing that that amount of tax.
I posted this the other day on
Instagram,
but just chimps testicle in relationship
to the size of his brain.
It's testicle is literally about 70 to
80 percent of the size of its brain.
Oh my God,
I got a fair amount.
70.
Think 70 is accurate at something like
that.
It's made wrong.
Yeah.
What is balls?
One ball is 70 percent the size of the
brain.
Two balls.
Balls are almost a whole.
Brain is weird,
right?
Poor guys.
It's so big.
You know what?
The ball's in front of us.
This is a little perspective trick.
Yeah,
true.
Because that guy's hands.
That's not one above the other.
It's one behind the other and the other
hand looks bigger and blacker.
It's a different guy,
different guy.
These flocks.
Yeah.
Maybe if they got it right up next to
it,
we don't want to go 40 percent.
Either way.
It's a giant ball.
I'd be very proud of that.
Testicle,
testicle like that.
Show everybody.
So knowing that there's that many shark
attacks,
will you not go snorkel next time you
go?
Um,
I'll tell you what.
I was thinking about going to Paris this
year and I'm not going to Paris.
You're not.
Nah,
I'm good.
My parents made that call to.
Yeah,
I think that's the right call for me for
now.
You have some giant ass fucking crazy
terrorist attack like that and you
haven't heard any issues with immigrants
and all the craziness that's going on
there.
Like they,
you know,
they might've let some bad people in the
country,
they let some great people that were
trying to escape a terrible place,
but they also might have let some bad
people into.
And there's a lot of fucking anti Jewish
sentiment.
Although I'm not Jewish.
I know video of these people walking
through these Arab neighborhoods and
Paris and the fucking rampant,
brutal,
like outright antisemitism,
yelling it out.
These people.
Really?
That's not America.
I think you know,
we're.
We're,
you're dealing with.
It's a very tricky place right now.
Now.
It's such a shame.
It's a really beautiful.
I know.
Stunning.
So historically
with any update on the war,
they declared war on Isis.
Isis.
Has it gotten even that man?
I mean,
what?
What happened over there?
I don't even understand what happened.
It's when,
when you have a group of people and
those people that wanted to performing
that terrorist act,
wind up dying like,
boy,
try getting the truth out of all that.
Trying to figure out what their motives
were,
what like the San Bernardino people.
Try figuring that out after the fact.
Trying to figure that out.
I'm not going to San Bernardino either.
Dropping your kids off and it's not
true.
San Bernardino.
That's how a hypocrite I am.
I won't go to Paris to go to San
Bernardino.
Bet you go to Paris if someone gave you
a sweet gig there.
No,
no,
I don't think so.
That's a brutal flight to man a Gig.
Eight is I would way rather go there and
just vegetate and not have any
responsibility.
Then you go there for.
That's one thing that I've really
enjoyed about traveling is that I've.
I've gotten a chance to see some really
cool places like England,
Ireland,
but one of the things that's an issue is
every time I've gone I've been working.
Yeah,
just don't have a chance to see that
much now.
I went to Italy for the first time and
no Gig at all and I don't travel like
that either.
You know?
Normally.
And what a difference.
Oh yeah,
what a difference.
But man,
we,
you know,
like I don't know how you are,
but see if I fly to Chicago and I got a
Gig tomorrow night in Chicago,
I'm going to get something to eat and
I'm gonna go to the gym and I'm going to
go over my notes.
Right?
I'm not going anywhere.
No I can't.
No.
People are like,
Yo,
don't you go sightseeing.
They don't realize that everything you
do during that day takes away from the
show.
Yeah.
There's just an energy,
mental and physical energy that does not
end up in the show unless it's something
that's going to enhance the show.
Like going over your notes like that,
sitting there but not running around
town.
Getting cabs do,
talking to waiters,
sometimes a little bit of activity and
sightseeing can amp you up,
you know,
little you have to have the time to do
it and it can't be taken away from.
Like for me,
exercise is mandatory.
Yeah.
Like if I go on the road,
one of the most important things for me
is almost immediately I have to
exercise.
Really?
Yeah.
Because if I don't then I'm going to be
tired,
but I'll get there and I'm like,
oh,
fucking flying.
Oh Bullshit.
But what you gotta do is say,
shut up pussy.
Just put your fucking shorts on and
let's do this.
What floors Jim on.
Thank you.
Here we go.
Get on the fucking machine and just go.
Just go or a routine,
whatever I'm doing whatever weight
lifting routine.
I just fucking make sure I do it.
I don't want to do it,
but I actually had a boss.
I should do that more.
If you do that,
man,
I'm telling you,
just write it down so that it's not an
option to deny like unless you're sick
or something like that and then you
definitely shouldn't work out.
Right.
But if you can do that,
just it's just,
it's 40 minutes that you would just be
jerking off and reading email.
It's true.
Totally split.
That 40 minutes will go by and you're
like,
fuck,
I missed the window.
I've done that before too.
I've definitely done that before.
You're tired.
Yes.
But when I,
when I say no,
I'm going to go down there and
I'm going to do you know,
whatever,
45 minutes on the elliptical machine.
Just go.
Just do it.
Listen to a podcast.
I'll put a podcast on.
Just forced myself.
Yeah.
I just,
I do a couple of yoga stretches.
That's good.
That'll help.
That is.
There's nothing now.
There's a couple of that are.
For me it showed strenuous exercise is
really good for just resetting
everything that your whole nervous
system.
Do you ever do a yoga class when you go
on the road?
Yeah,
I have.
Yeah.
I have for awhile when I was heavily
more heavily into it,
I would,
it was Kinda cool.
You come into town and find where it was
and you know,
it was a cool little like,
okay,
that's the project I'm going to do that,
you know,
that's a good move.
Good move.
Something that you just have an outlet.
Yeah.
Little thing that sort of connects you
to what Tom Papa does.
Right?
Exactly.
And then uh,
and then it's just the work,
it's just taking your notebook and
taking your notes and going over last
night going over the,
you know,
what I did for the first time this week,
I've listened to myself.
I haven't,
I haven't recorded myself in a while.
Really?
Yeah,
it was probably,
I always record but don't really listen
to it unless I know I have to.
There was something I want to pick out
and uh,
I listened to myself on a Sunday after
the weekend and,
uh,
that was rough.
You forget,
you're like,
oh yeah,
I should be doing this all the time.
It's so valuable.
It's incredibly valuable.
Visually is even better.
I know.
You can watch a video of yourself and
you go,
oh my God,
I look so gross.
I gotTa pee.
I gotta dress better.
My posture sucks.
Why does my ever move my right arm?
Why am I like a real thing?
I'm doing my hand in my pocket.
Get it out of your pocket at the Irvine
Improv.
That guy he did every set and just hand
them to me.
Those are great.
Oh,
nice house does that too.
I was like,
oh,
thanks.
Have you formed at the recent Irvine
Improv?
The new one?
Yeah.
Nice.
Really Nice theater.
Yeah,
Collin did his,
a comedy special.
They're really special there.
I was like,
that's a good call.
Yeah.
There's places as places hot.
It looked great.
The backstage was grieving greg.
It was a good spot.
That town,
like Irvine is a town where there's so
many fucking people jammed into that
area.
It's shocking,
isn't it?
It is one of the most populated areas in
southern California.
Why did you guys come from like me and
my wife were talking about this the
other day that there's such a big
difference between driving up like we're
like thousand oaks is and driving down
Orange County like thousand oaks.
Things lighten up considerably.
That's right.
You know,
it's like fucking horses.
You should up there,
but if you get down to like Laguna.
Yeah,
good luck.
Good luck getting there and time.
It's intense.
Do you ever do gigs in San Diego that
drive?
You might as well just drive to the
fucking ocean.
Let's see if your car can make it.
See if you could just drive on the edge
of the water.
I take the train a lot.
Oh,
you ever do that?
No,
I've never done that,
but I was just thinking,
no wonder if you could drive in the
ocean if they arrest you.
What are they actually in the ocean and
you're driving your car.
They let you go.
What kind of car?
Well,
if you have one of those cars,
the snorkel,
that's what I'm thinking.
If you've got like one of them Toyota
land cruisers,
they put a snorkel on them and they
drive to the river and the fucking
Amazon like you would think they'd let
you go.
The sharks might get you.
Do they let you do that?
Like how does that work?
Like with the coastguard k fuck face,
you can't just drive in the ocean.
Probably not.
I thought about the same thing in a
similar vein.
Can you just go on horseback down?
Ventura could just get a horse and go to
the bank that way.
That's very,
very good point.
Could you just tired horse up to the
bike rack and walk inside and you cash a
check?
Well,
it's always weird if you go to burbank
and you see people riding their horses
around.
Burbank.
Burbank is an equestrian neighborhood.
My daughter was taking lessons over
there for a little bit with the,
okay,
here's this Guy Perth,
Australia.
Oh,
that guy just drove right in.
I'm just driving in.
That's just stupid.
You can't do that.
Is this guy tried watchmen drive current
into the ocean?
The ocean from the cops I think.
Oh,
he's trying to get away from.
Okay,
well that's different.
And so now he's driving off and the cops
tried to get them so they drove right
into the ocean.
This guy's an idiot.
See the car doesn't.
It doesn't end.
Once the hood is underwater.
Dip Shit for him.
That's what the snorkels for for it.
But the thing that the cops behind him
like,
well he's going hop out of the car and
just swim.
Yeah,
he's out now.
But the thing is if you,
if you have a car with a snorkel and he
doesn't have a car with a snorkel,
you can drive pretty far and they can't
get you.
Like you could stay up but he could just
drive next to you on the beach and
eventually got to come to the land.
Look at this crazy clusterfuck of cops
and the car.
Is this an Australia or something?
A course.
How did you say it?
At the beginning?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's it.
Because otherwise I'm like,
there's no way I just guessed,
but why not?
Just get a horse and code,
run your errands.
That.
How about an Eagle Eagle to fly around
managing so many.
Just developed an like look,
grab onto his talents.
Have you ever seen a pit bull that's
like 190 pounds?
Yeah.
They're not supposed to be that big.
Right?
Somebody made that.
They bred those pitbulls until it became
this ridiculous thing.
The average size for Pitbull,
those fighting dogs,
they're like 35 pounds.
I got big ones.
Like 50.
Really?
Yeah.
They're not big.
So these monsters are like chickens with
giant breasts,
sort of,
which also comes from selective
breeding.
Apparently I thought the chickens with
giant breasts were steroids,
but uh,
this chicken farmer explained to me,
you know,
because you know,
how much,
how expensive it would be really pumped
with.
We have this idea,
oh,
they're putting all the hormones and not
really.
No,
no,
they,
I mean,
they would,
if they had to fix on something crazy.
But most of it is.
Yeah.
Most of it is they genetically engineer
them.
These selectively breed them.
So they get,
they selectively breed them to the point
where they could barely even walk.
It's poor things that they can't stay on
their leg.
So for at least how this guy has
explained it to her,
it's mostly just selective breeding.
And why can they do that with an eagle?
Get a big ass.
Big Ass fucking eagle.
Have you could teach an eagle to hunt
for wolves for you.
Have you ever seen them do that?
No.
Yeah,
the Mongolians.
Oh really?
They lead an eagle loose in the eagle
will fucking fly down and Jack a wolf,
a wolf,
a wolf.
Those are big.
They're not big enough.
That's how gangster eagles are.
I'm reading that book.
The Hawk.
What's that girl?
Uh,
just loved.
Um,
it's her autobiography basically he's
just a writer out of Oxford and she is
learning how to uh,
train,
uh,
go shock and awe falcons and all that
kind of stuff with the hoods and very
intricate about that whole practice is
pretty intense.
It's very intense getting into trust you
and they're in its hood.
You have to be with it all the time.
All the time,
like in the beginning,
like for days,
just sitting with it on your arm.
Can you go on vacations new?
Yeah.
You can't just take a month off.
I'm just going to hang out with puking.
Yeah,
eat your face.
It's a little hood.
But why couldn't someone engineer an
eagle?
That was your buddy that flies you
around like a fly back early.
This wolf jacking.
There's a wolf jacking in Eagle and the
eagle comes down.
Jackson Wolf.
Oh Shit.
Like that?
Both jacket.
This is insane.
So the wolf was kicking the eagles ass
and his home.
He came in and backed him up.
See,
you shouldn't worry about the monkeys
because these guys are doing this now.
See?
I think as men,
but these eagles are so god damn tough
and their claws are so fucking
terrifying.
They essentially have knives.
Yeah,
they're growing their feet.
They're fucking dinosaurs,
man.
He says this is a dinosaur that made it
right and it makes me wonder what
dinosaurs actually looked like.
Like we always assume that all dinosaurs
were covered with scales like a
crocodile and show.
A lot of them will look at this,
see there,
duking it out.
The Eagle lands on him,
started jacking them shoes and he's got
them.
He's got him by the neck.
Oh my God.
It's insane.
He's killing is just.
He just got full mount on the wolf and
he's clawing them to death.
He just keeps committed distance.
Yeah.
And the Eagles fucked.
He's got his neck.
This is insane.
It's insane that they can do this.
That is nuts.
That's a big ass ego.
That's a Golden Eagle.
And that's a small wolf by the way.
Those are not as big as it looks like a
mid dog.
This is crazy though,
man.
Now would see feeding him.
He's giving him a reward.
Is given them some meat.
Uh,
yeah.
Always holding the glove meat of
the carcass.
Gets them back on his arm in the hood.
Goes on.
Yeah.
Wow.
Jeez.
What a wonderful but terrifying animal.
It's a cool hobby.
You know,
it's not like bread making bread,
but where's this starter?
They,
um,
they showed these.
They had these ancient hominid bones
they found and they were trying to
figure out why they had these claw marks
on them and they were trying to figure
out what animal had done it,
and then they recognize very similar
patterns of scrapes to what they find on
small primates that are near heartbeat
eagles,
and they realized that early humans were
most likely eaten by eagles.
Really?
Yeah.
A bigger eagle.
Like a pterodactyl sizing gang of
different kinds of birds and large
predatory birds.
Yeah.
In fact,
North America,
like I believe before,
like,
oh,
I don't want to say how long ago,
but I don't think it was too long ago.
Like not even a million years.
They had a thing called a Tara Byrd.
Tera Byrd was like a giant seven foot
tall predatory bird that didn't fly.
It was like a Standing Burger.
Giant beat.
Like a huge predatory Karl Malone sized
bird.
That's crazy.
How about that?
Let's make that movie.
How about a magic Johnson sized bird
with a giant fucking hatchet for a face?
Not even flying.
I don't have to.
Yeah.
You should see that they do a
superimposed image of the size of a
normal human,
like have a six foot tall humans next to
a terror or like what they looked like.
I love Tara Byrd.
That's a generic name isn't a
terrifying,
and this is North America.
This is right here.
She's.
Yeah,
so there was A.
I mean the entire fossil record even
just of males is not complete.
There's,
they're always finding new things
because in order to create a fossil,
it's very difficult to like something
has to happen.
You have to get caught in the mud
sliders.
Jamie,
see if he could find a terror picture.
I'd love to see thing.
Look at that fucking thing as a soldier
that gets eat.
The one in the left that looks like
where the wild things are.
Yeah.
It doesn't even look like it's a real
thing.
Look at the size of that fucking thing.
It's eggs must be huge.
Oh my God.
Like ahead.
Yeah.
Bigger,
bigger.
Look at the size of that fucker.
Wasn't there a movie where people riding
those?
Maybe,
but it's interesting that one of them
has fairly large wings.
The one on the right,
but the one on the left has like these
nubs.
Yeah.
He's like all different terror birds.
All fucking cry.
Oh my God.
The one in the forefront.
The one that the evil red looking beak
and the one in the backgrounds like that
one's like almost flamingo ostrich
monster.
Could you imagine if you were just
walking along and you saw something
popping its head out of the trees
looking at you funny.
It's that
size and you go,
oh my God,
it's over.
It's over.
My Cat's been on a bird killing spree.
Good for her or him.
Brings in a couple of week.
Really?
It's really out of hand.
Well,
you get better.
Be careful if you let your cat out
because you can get jacked by coyote.
No,
it's his.
It's his life.
Wow.
That's brutal clause or no claws.
Claws.
Scott clause.
And you let them scan.
He's an outdoor and he just.
He's a nut.
He can't see who's been an outdoor cat.
Yeah.
Does he come inside at all?
Comes in place in your house.
Now they do.
If you don't get them fixed quick
enough.
I have an indoor cat,
an indoor and outdoor.
My minor,
both indoor because,
um,
I live in a place where a lot of coyotes
are.
I guess my,
one of my chickens got jacked by a
coyote.
I watched it happen.
I would have hopped the fence.
My chicken in his mouth.
Yeah.
We had a separate chickens get broody
means they,
um,
they,
they get confused since they're not
getting fucked by roosters.
Sometimes they think that they have an
egg that they have to hatch,
that they have to,
uh,
you know,
what's that called?
What's it called?
The nurture and egg to sit on it.
Yeah.
Who,
something again,
what's the word?
I'm just state.
No,
that's not a um,
um,
lay on top of what's it called?
Like when you take an egg and you put it
in one of those warming things,
you like lamp goes.
People will listen to this screaming you
fucking planet.
Even Remember,
Oh,
I knew it was a,
I was trying to avoid the band incubus.
Um,
but anyway,
um,
it was,
it was thinking,
it was thinking that,
so we have to take them out and she had
to get outside of regular chicken coop.
It's just large coop and you have to put
her in one where she has to sit on a
beam.
It's a very small for the amount of time
they broody that's how much time you
have to put them in there.
Otherwise they could be broody for like
a month.
They'll pull their,
their feathers out,
cause some health issues.
They pluck the feathers out of their
chest to feather their nest for an egg
that's not going to hatch.
They get a little wacky,
weird.
Well their brains are fucking thumbnail,
right?
So,
uh,
this coyote just figured out a way to
get into that little cage and jack the
chicken and jumped over the fence with
it.
Yeah,
I mean it's definitely a risk.
And a couple of neighbors,
one neighbor lost a cat,
you know,
like 10 years ago too.
It's not,
it's like the beginning of coyote.
It gives us not a lot going on,
but enough where if the cat's not smart
but it could happen,
but the cat is so happy and that's just
the way he lives and it's like,
you know.
Yeah.
You know,
we.
Everyone would be sad,
but yes.
His life.
Yeah.
It's probably not the worst way to go
either quick rather than getting
diabetes and cancer.
Diabetes.
Yeah.
I hit a diabetic.
Can't whoa.
So you have to give you the insulin.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Every day.
Twice.
That's probably pissed at you.
Didn't.
I had no idea why you shoot me this
fucking needle.
Bitch.
I want pets putting a pill on a,
like a sticky as a fire and its throat.
That's how you do it.
That's one of the things that.
And the insula.
He probably.
Did he run from you all the time now?
He was pretty mellow.
He's probably extended his life for
another four years.
Oh.
And then,
uh,
it just all ended up failing,
but you know,
it was like I will,
you know,
it was my wife's cat.
If I would have,
you would have ended up probably would
not have shots for that long hatchet,
which is Rosen method.
Just opened the door and make coyote
calls.
Yeah,
it was a,
it was a nice cat.
But yeah,
I never knew there was this thing as a
diabetic cat and uh,
yeah,
we extended his life for awhile and then
uh,
you know,
the other things start to fail.
You try feeding him a Vegan Diet?
No,
it's supposed to cure diabetes.
Oh yeah.
No,
I can things up.
But people do have their cats and they
feed them vegan food.
Really?
Yeah.
Cats die young.
Sad irony.
And their attempt to not be cruel to
animals.
They're cruel to the animals at the
feeding and fucking plums cell range.
I just saw this 30 year old dog
yesterday on the Internet.
Have you ever heard of.
That's crazy.
What kind of dirty?
It's an Australian.
They can't prove how old it really is,
but oh,
there's some video of it.
I mean,
it looks like it's fucking 30 in dog
years.
That's 36 years old.
Oh Wow.
That's crazy.
30 [inaudible] the owners must be like,
all right,
dude.
See here,
there's no proof.
As long as there's no proof and we're
reading about this,
we have no fucking idea how old that
dog.
This is a bullshit story.
That's the problem with God damn
stories.
It's all you have to do is you get paid
per ad clicks.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just put a picture up and that's it.
See like that.
Three men who admitted to raping a girl.
17 won't be jailed.
That's a lie too.
Must read and this guy's got his abs out
there taking the photo.
What are you trying to do?
You're trying to get me to click so it
might not be about that.
No associated with it.
And then someone will get paid.
Tom,
Papa,
we have run out of time here really
quick.
I know that was three hours of fun,
my friend.
It's crazy.
It was great though.
It really crazy.
Enjoyed talking to you,
man.
Thank you.
I,
you know,
I've been here once before and I've been
itching to get back.
It's good.
Hang.
I think this was better than our first
one.
Yeah,
I really do.
I do a lot of starters.
I learned about a lot about yeast and,
and muscle tissue.
Now you to get me,
get me a hot car and do that.
We'll do that when we get off there.
I'll show you how to do it.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it for the week.
Me,
you fucks.
The next week.
I've got four of them,
so straddle up,
got a lot of love.
And start with Cameron Hanes on Monday.
Um,
uh,
my friend Doug,
during this coming next week I got a but
no Saratu.
Oh boss ruin.
And tomorrow Rinella are going to be
here.
And Robin Black.
It's going to be a hell of a week.
You have.